Yo,
what
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight bought
to you by several things were brought to
you for you guys.
This is the most important part.
Were brought together the whole thing.
It's all for you.
It's all for you,
but we've got to pay bills than with
cost money.
What's that?
Dramatic opening by the way?
You had this fucking too high to talk.
How to wait a few seconds and wait for
the moment to achieve me.
We did the music after the commercials,
so it's easy to edit if somebody wants
to.
Nobody wants to listen.
These goddamn commercials I'd have to
do.
I'm back.
Joe.
I've returned.
What was the last time you used your
flashlight?
A.
Actually,
I use it all weekend because my girl was
at avn was really hard because every hot
girl was outside of Los Angeles and went
to Vegas.
It seemed like.
No.
So you had a hard time masturbating
pretending on hot girls in town.
Right?
What a fucking twisted world you live
in.
Where you think that all went.
All the porn stars are out of town.
Well,
no more attractive now.
There's like an energy in the air,
you know,
and if it leaves,
it's like a ghost town.
It feels really empty inside.
Your world is inexorably tied to the
porn world at this point.
That's why.
Yeah,
it's weird.
it's very strange.
You live a strange life,
my friend.
Yeah.
So you had to like beat it all weekend.
Yeah,
I did.
I went crazy.
I went ape shit.
Nice.
It's a solid product.
That flashlight.
It's a.
I'll tell you what,
just just for sheer impact of
effectiveness,
efficacy is better than anything we
promote.
It's better than any of the vitamins.
It's better than anything,
but it's nice to have mental clarity.
But to really be able to shoot fucking
blasto loads like,
like you can with a flashlight.
Have you seen that thing that they may.
One of our,
uh,
rants on past podcasts where it's an
ipad holder that you can kind of attach
a fleshlight yeah.
And so now you can sit there and they
had this porn,
like first person shooter type form that
you sit there and watch on your ipad
while it.
And holding it while it's connected to
your flashlight.
It's just the beginning.
Just the beginning.
It's once it goes virtual,
that's when things are going to be
really strange when there's somehow or
another,
like the put a helmet on you and then
the fleshlight moves up and down your
Dick.
And probably like a bunch of flashlights
all over your body by doing right.
Joey,
Joey.
Anyway,
the flashlights should be.
You should be able to take the Alpha
brains and fuck the fleshlight.
You shouldn't combine.
That's,
that's the secret right there.
Yeah.
Chemists to be too smart while you're
fucking of fake pussy.
Better off.
Like we have like Alpha dumb pills,
mushrooms,
psychedelic trip as you fucking coming.
So let's say you fucked a purple one.
You'd think of purple things.
I don't know.
I would like to know what my Iq is when
I have a hard on because I bet it's
half.
Yeah.
I would like to know what my Iq is when
I have a book in three thinking nothing
else.
It's amazing.
You know,
women realize that,
you know,
when they realized that when they try to
become men like Chaz Bono,
you know,
she's,
one of the things she's saying is like
now she understands like male behavior.
She does it.
She understands it.
She understands she was,
she understands.
Yes.
She's been a man.
Go get your two year old and say she's
all fucking fat with that fucking bitch.
You don't trick me.
You don't like that beard.
I just don't listen to people want to
have parties for a little while.
She's going into a deep water here.
She made the conversion.
She went right beep into being a fucking
man because you strap a pair on and
don't.
Like I said today,
you can't fucking to just drop a pair
and nuggets on and go out there and
sling.
I always fucking know that you're the
real deal.
You know who you kidding?
You Been Sucking Dick for 20 years.
Now you want to change.
Fucking governments can't do that shit.
You can change government changing
government.
It's two different.
Fucking world's man,
a fucking woman.
I.
You know what ma'am?
Wouldn't you hate to have been born?
What if you imagined you were man,
but you were really a woman.
You really wish you were a woman like
that would fucking be so frustrating.
Gotcha it.
Well,
what is it then?
What is it?
The people that do it is this,
you know,
which this is a fucking solid
conversation that we should actually.
Let's save this.
We're going to stop and then,
but when we come back,
we're going to talk about.
We're going to talk about that.
We're going to talk about that right
when we come back.
It's a solid conversation.
Go to Joe Rogan's website and click on
the click on the link for the code name,
Rogan,
and you get 15 percent off.
15.
It's a fucking solid product.
Tremendous.
The other products were sponsored by is
from onnit.com,
o n n I t if you don't like it,
make your own.
You know?
Yeah,
we've already got that.
I know what I liked.
I liked.
I liked it.
I've never used the flashlight,
but what I like about it right now,
thinking about it,
at least you know what you're fucking
tropical helmet.
Juices going sometimes when you open
your eyes,
you don't know what the fuck.
Yeah.
Look,
sometimes you find on your foot in the
flashlight,
it goes right to the bottom,
like Hershey's chocolate.
Goes back to the step mother fucked up.
And you're backpage.
That's right.
Exactly.
And the coupon code for Oh,
for,
on it.
Well,
who is as.
I mean,
who is it?
Who's that in the back?
Oh,
what?
I don't know.
All right.
So anyways,
go to Joe's
over here.
Um,
sounded like me.
You're watching videos of me talking to
my dog.
Fuck.
It.
Sounded like.
Hey twix ice or something like that.
Wow,
that's creepy.
Just kidding.
What is it to your computer?
No,
somebody's computer was making all that
noise.
My computer was not on holidays or off.
What the fuck happened?
We'll let start this motherfucker.
Joe Rogan is Alpha brain would help us
solve this conundrum of where the fuck
the sound came from and what it was that
had to be your shit.
Dude,
no it wasn't.
It couldn't have been mine.
There was nothing on mine when I went
back there.
Is there,
right?
If you'd like to look at videos to get
it.
I am on Alpha brain.
You cannot sneak by me with your
childish games.
They don't work.
I see him.
I see the plan.
I see the matrix.
What's fucking dylan?
How dare you?
I think we've got Brian A.
Little too high.
I don't think.
I don't think he can do it.
Okay.
It was a beeper,
right?
We are.
Um,
I'm not on Alpha brain right now.
That's the problem.
Alpha brain is the cognitive enhancing
supplement offered by [inaudible] dot
com.
We also have shroom tech sport,
which is a quarter [inaudible] mushrooms
a supplement,
which is great for endurance working out
like Jujitsu.
You want to get your Jujitsu on,
you want to do some crossfit or
something crazy like that.
It's great if you're a sedentary
individual,
no need.
There's another product called shroom
tech,
immune Zm,
mune boosting supplement.
All the information is available on
[inaudible] Dot Com,
o n n I,
t and a,
as we always say for real,
and this is not just lip service.
If you think this stuff cost too much,
please steal the ingredient list and
not.
Don't steal it,
just copy it down and and and duplicate
it yourself by the stuff in bulk and
taking care of yourself mega yourself
and I hope you do and I hope you enjoy
it and if you are interested and you do
try,
but it doesn't work for you,
you don't like it,
you don't believe in it,
it just doesn't.
You don't find it effective.
You get a hundred percent of your money
back,
100 percent.
You don't have to send in the product.
You don't have to.
You just tell us you're not happy and
it's over.
We try to make it as easy and as clean
and as ethical as possible.
I believe in nootropics.
I've been taking them for a long time.
If you're interested in them,
you should research them.
You should go online and Google it and
look up the different.
There's a bunch of different companies
and have a bunch of different
proprietary blends of different
nootropics and uh,
there's all different.
Nootropics have different effects on
different people.
It's a fascinating,
fascinating stuff.
Please Google it,
check it out.
But if you want to buy our stuff or you
won't even check that out at all.
O n n I t.com,
use the code name.
Rogan.
You get 10 percent off.
Joe Diaz is here.
Bitches were ready to break shit down.
This is the week of the Chicago theater
would come in.
Chicago dirty bitches podcast also
brought to you by olive garden.
Mentioned Olive Garden.
Get 10 percent off.
Nothing.
Red Band.
Talk About Olive Garden.
Red Bang.
Oh,
said God,
you just
killed his own.
I've gotten bit.
Send it to get out in the middle of a
fucking talking about hunting.
Steven Rinella.
Brian goes like olive garden.
No,
motherfucker.
Whenever I talked to Brian and I have
the podcasts,
go to a great.
Did you mention my olive garden?
You know,
it kind of sucks about that whole thing
that everyone now takes pictures while
they're at the olive garden and sends
them to me.
So I get so tired of looking at olive
garden like that is not like.
Honestly I don't give a shit about the
olive garden even though people fled my
twit stream with all of you.
Love it.
Like I love [inaudible].
Oh,
coconut water.
That did just sent me some more.
So thank you.
See Two old people and I got to thank
Grillo's pickles too.
Remember we were talking about that.
A pickle company in Boston that had
these homemade pickles and we're selling
them in the park and I'll fucking.
Awesome.
Now they got ahold of me and they sent
me some.
Oh you fucking.
Oh my God.
He's a fucking pickles are ridiculous
dude.
They have these hot Habanero pickles,
pickles with like slices of Jalapeno and
Habanero in it.
They're like really spicy pickles.
Damn.
They're good.
Feel like fresh and just crispin woo
sliced cheese burger.
Tremendous fucking serious pickles.
I know.
It seems like I'm excited about talking
about Chaz.
Chaz Bono.
That's what is,
you know,
was crazy by Chaz Bono.
She's got to look like Ralphie May.
Once she had the surgery,
was like fuck,
I mean Chaz Bono is that,
that is the most amusing story to me of
last year and I don't fuck with it
really.
I just don't fuck with it.
It's just the,
it's just creeps me to fuck out one way
or the other.
I don't know why I feel really bad for
you.
No,
I uh,
I just feel like if you,
if you're going to go through with that
for I feel bad for one way or the other,
either I feel bad for her because she
really is a man trapped in a woman's
body and that must be really frustrating
or I feel bad for that.
She's,
you know,
she's in this state of disarray where
that's the option and you've got to go
through surgery and it just seems to me
like anybody that would need to do that
for any reason just to actually change
and try to become something else and
become some different sex,
you know,
that's,
that's a,
that's a deep dissatisfaction with your
current life and you know,
who's to say that maybe her solution
isn't becoming a man to play rugby first
and then come back.
You know what I'm saying?
I like to know she's happier now mean
that there'll be an interesting call.
I knew I knew a comedian in Seattle that
was a man and became a woman.
Had the surgery,
the whole psychological one through the
whole thing.
And uh,
it was hard on her.
Her name was Rita.
Oh,
her head was fucking huge.
Time to time.
That's how she died.
She fucked up.
God was too big.
She was at a club.
She fucking went down like a boxer named
Rita.
Oh,
well,
you know what happened to.
He's in a white,
I think Seattle.
I'm not joking.
I wish I was,
but I'm not joking.
She used to,
we used to stay at brody,
Stevens and me used to steal her Nachos
at open mic and she had a womanly voice
and when we were still on Nachos she'd
say pour them the fuck down.
We would just stop.
I robbed the bank.
100 values from her and she put a gun to
my head.
This bitch,
she was five foot two and she died maybe
two years after I moved out of Seattle
as brody when,
when she got she got the full operation.
You've got to get the full moon when
they,
when you do that,
your body really like shrinks up their
mass.
Right.
And maybe maybe you really,
if you have a big head and maybe it will
work as long as you have a big body to
go with it,
but if you have a big hand a little bit
like that,
like dad actually does make sense that
she would be like,
she was often because your muscles go
away with the size of your head is like.
And her drug problem was,
uh,
it was just horrendous.
The drug problem that she had from the
pain,
like and one night from the pain of the
surgery,
like know the pain of.
She just drank every night.
She didn't leave the house without a
bottle in her purse.
I mean,
Geez,
one night we did an open mic and the guy
threw her out of Arab throughout.
She went home and we talked to her into
calling the White House.
It was the cocaine we played.
You got to call the White House.
Do you remember that dude?
He used to come around.
The comedy store's Kinda.
It was Kinda half homeless,
half crossdresser type character.
The black guy was his name.
Boom.
Shaka Laka my ship from my girlfriend
from that guy like faces and shoes and a
half a hooker.
I love bikes with a fucking.
He's had some nutty moments,
man.
One time when he was in the back of the
comedy store and he was like yelling at
no one in particular,
fuck this motherfucker like really mad
at somebody and he went and stormed into
the little bathroom there was washing up
in the air and they were trying to get
rid of them.
They're trying to calm her down and get
him off the porch.
I don't know exactly what happened,
but I was like,
wow,
this dude's fucking mad.
Some shit's about to go down.
Well they would tease him on Sunday
nights and torture him and then he would
go fucking awol black on you.
Fuck this motherfucker.
I'll kill you and all this shit.
There's something that happened with him
and Dan by Bilac Bilac.
But yeah,
it's something happy between those
tickets.
He always carries around signs and
things like going against him.
So I think or maybe it's vice versa.
I don't know.
You don't know what the story is,
but I'll talk about that tonight at
another park,
Bro.
Be the Friday night meeting you and
Duncan trussell.
Let me tell say I've been excited about
going to Chicago.
Chicago is one of those cities that you
know nothing.
It's always like you never really think
about you.
You're on your way there.
Then you get excited.
You get really fucking excited.
We're going down to the city,
great fights.
You know the great Italian food,
great Polish food does everything that
everything per roghey's stakes.
We're in the Midwest and one other
thing.
You better dress warm motherfucker.
It's called the cops that arrested Tony
Montana at time for fucking money.
Laundry.
Mom,
you said you'd been addressed?
Warm is going to be fucking cold.
Will go on in the,
in the nucleus of the winter,
the last week of January that the
fucking storm says the [inaudible] days
and cold and you have a winter jacket.
Fuck yeah,
I do.
You can have one of my man.
I have boxes of them.
I've got an awesome fucking believable
that will go on into the wind,
will go into the eye of the storm.
So awesome.
And I don't give a fuck.
I'm redheaded child son and base being,
oh my gosh,
I'm Chael Sonnen and bisping is going to
be fucking crazy.
I just wished that fight could take
place a couple months from now instead
of like this weekend.
So I want to hear more trash talking
from these guys.
I want to hear more.
Not even try.
I mean they're not even trash talk and
like,
you know,
bisping is confident as fuck man,
this is going to be real interesting.
I think on the people sleep on this
thing for some reason I don't sleep on
those things.
He's a bad business and it's going to be
a.
he's one of the fittest guys at one 85
too.
He's very fit.
He's like,
he's a dedicated athlete and like he
puts a pace on dudes mad,
you know,
a lot of sick people say made him look
really bad.
And then in the last fight may have
definitely looked bad,
but one of the,
part of the reason why he looked bad
because Michael bisping look good.
He looks sharp,
man.
His standup was sharp,
his conditioning sharpest.
Fucking his defense was sharp when the
fight went to the ground,
everything was good man.
And he,
he put it on mayhem.
And you saw like an evolution of him
over the last few years,
you know,
you,
you can see in the Jorge reverify,
see in this fight and the mayhem fight
really in the mayhem fight,
you really see it.
Like he's turned a serious fucking
corner.
You know Michael.
But Michael Bisping's dangerous.
And you know what I loved about the
fight after it was over,
he was upset at himself for the first
round,
even though he had this like flawless
performance and virtually shut out
mayhem,
you know,
until the fight got stopped.
Once he got up to his feet,
the second round started,
he just shut him down,
just completely shut him down.
And if you.
And if you see that you would think,
well he should be happy,
but he wasn't happy.
And one of the first things he said was
that he was upset at his performance in
the first round.
Wasn't going to do if you ever fought
the champion.
Does the first thing you said.
So there's a guy who's not even not even
congratulating them himself for,
you know,
he had this big rivalry with may hand.
They went through a whole season of the
ultimate fighter together,
talk to all kinds of shit to each other,
and he just fucked him up and he wasn't
even being like congratulatory about it.
He was concentrating on what he didn't
do well,
but he wanted to own them perfectly.
You know what I see with him is his life
has come full circle.
He's come,
he's become completely moved his family
over from England.
He's training down in Orange County.
He's got his family with them,
which makes a big difference when you
fucking training.
He already took the knockout.
No,
he got that knock out again.
Tennis and he caught himself,
found himself and he's ready.
He's ready.
He's much better now.
Yeah,
he's much better now.
He's a better place if they say it's
hard
for a fighter to rebound from a loss
like that,
you know,
it's very difficult.
I mean,
I can only imagine.
I'm only speculating,
but from what I've experienced watching
people,
you know,
fighters will change from losses.
Catch
fucking knock Gavigan tendus and
that'll,
you know,
just getting beat up at the fucking
pizza parlor.
Changes a motherfucker want to knock out
like that
came back strong.
Dennis Kang and one of the big things is
Dennis Kang caught him.
Remember Dennis Kang tagged and with the
right hand,
dropped them a jumped on him,
but he stayed calm.
He used his guard,
he had a real good defensive guard,
locked them up.
And then the second run he beat the shit
out of him today.
Know people sleep on them.
Man.
I don't know why it's real weird.
It's like I,
I see them sleeping on him and I think
it's because maybe you see a guy lose
once and you think that's how the guy
flights,
you know,
instead of saying it's looking at the
whole picture,
that motherfucker had a draw with
Rashad.
Dude.
You know,
he didn't he or was it Tito?
How to draw with them?
No,
it was,
uh,
did he lose to Rashad?
I think it was a draw.
What's the draw?
Okay.
I don't know.
I feel like I feel like I just made that
up.
But it was,
yeah,
let me check.
Let me look under shirt.
Org Dot net.
Oh,
someone.
Someone from shirt or wrote some whole
thing saying that I hate shirt off
because I was talking shit about their
forums.
Listen man,
I don't particularly completely hate
anybody.
I'm sure your forums have some nice
people on it and every form has a bunch
of consulting including my own.
So I love all around vegges.
All right.
Um,
so yeah,
stats who would go,
bulk of them have a one at the end.
Yeah.
They say,
Hey,
let's just not make for fucking
thrilling podcast.
Yeah,
let's talk numbers.
Joy,
what would you say?
Uh,
his stats would be fucking stats.
I don't know who Brian is.
The girlfriend was doing his impression
right now of what he thinks like a
sportscaster would do.
He Won A.
Rashad wanted a decision,
you have it,
but you know,
he was fighting much bigger.
Guys should never been fighting it to.
Oh,
he's a tiny two old timey guy.
He's just not.
I would not say he's a tiny guy.
He's a big one.
80 five.
The first time I seen,
what's his name and uh,
in,
in Pittsburgh,
Anthony Johnson.
I thought he was a fucking defensive
tackle.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
those guys and being compared to the
hands of time.
Have you see,
you know,
when you see a WHO's the forrest
griffin?
I took the bait.
They released Anthony Johnson.
Yeah,
I know that.
That's.
What did you think the thing that was
gonna happen.
So I knew right then and there when you.
I read the twit.
I bet if he won,
if he won,
he probably would have been able to keep
his job.
He would had to come out and knock his
fucking head off in Brazil at home.
Knock him when he tried,
man,
I'm telling you,
he blew his wad going out and trying
because he tried to kill vetoer.
He went after him.
Man.
It was blue is one is actually a,
a gambling term,
Brian,
for you don't know.
It was a wad of cash.
And when you come out of the gates
strong and gambling and then you have no
more money.
It's called the blue.
It's white.
You Know Dana?
Dane is really fucking fair.
Dan is very fair.
No,
he listened to Anthony.
I think ms dot wait three times.
Yes,
and that's 12 pounds over that.
Well,
he had a medical situation this time.
I mean you can't.
He.
She was cutting too much,
but he had a medical situation this time
where he.
His legs stop working.
Right?
I heard that.
Which is fucking crazy.
It really stop and think these guys get
down to that dehydrated state and then
rehydrate up and fight the next day.
I mean it's.
Someone needs to talk to that dude and
say,
listen man,
you got it.
You don't need to put on any more
muscle.
Okay.
What you need to do is just lose some of
them.
Also.
You got legit.
Don't need to be that big.
You're a fucking monster.
Loose some of it.
You're going to fight it.
One 85.
You should walk around no bigger than
one 95.
Really?
You really shouldn't be cutting that
much weight.
You're a super athlete.
He's like totally selling himself short
by dehydrating himself and draining
himself for these fights.
So when it gets in like grueling fights,
like the cost check five,
he gets tired,
the vituro fight,
he gets tired.
Man,
I'm awesome.
Burns a lot.
But when burns even more is when you
dehydration,
hydrate the fuck out of your body,
you know,
I id hydrated my body when I fought and
taekwondo tournament.
So I did that to make way when I fought
it when I was in like 16,
I was fighting at 1:40
and I didn't weigh 1:40
and I didn't do it right either.
I would just like take hot showers and
take hot baths and not drink any water
for like a day.
And then I'd weigh in and I have to
rehydrate and fight that day.
And I know what it feels like.
It's a terrible feeling.
It makes you feel like shit to stupid
thing.
I mean I did it because it was an idiot
because I,
you know,
and I was being instructed that I should
stay in that weight class.
He's got 50 fucking pounds to cut.
He.
So the month before that.
Not only that dude,
he's so fucking big fucking pounds.
It is.
Muslims,
a lot of it's muscle mass,
muscle mass.
He's a super athlete.
That fucking guy,
man could be fighting it to look bad.
Pick on what's going on with the fucking
pickles.
And uh,
and the other thing.
Oh,
olive garden.
Ocean Boulevard,
ocean.
God.
Now who the fuck joey.
When is the last time you blew your wide
bullets?
What do you mean?
Gambling or just whacked?
Whacked off.
And who the fuck knows guy off the hump?
Pillows.
Do you take time?
No,
I work well from time to time.
The shower a couple of minutes here and
there or something.
I'd bang one out in my cappuccino style.
Does Chaz Bono have the Dick now?
Probably.
I mean I haven't asked her,
you know,
coffee being I'll say just show me that
fucking pickled.
It's really crazy that she,
you know,
she had a girlfriend and they broke up,
but you know,
the girlfriend was like,
she had a girlfriend and she was a girl
and then she decided she was a man.
And then the girl like,
could you imagine like if you're a
lesbian and then all sudden the person
that you're with becomes a man.
That's the best revenge ever.
This,
that's the best route.
You know,
I'll get back at,
you know,
and she'll get a couple of girlfriends.
She'll get a couple of girlfriends.
Novelty.
It's a
novelty.
Oh my God.
There.
Yeah.
And then you take them home and a dick.
Smells like a Twat.
And then you're saying you will see
after you ran three miles,
what's the difference that Dick and I
meet the fucking monkey here.
You know what the difference?
You can't take away the smell it.
You know,
you can't put a fake dick on.
It ain't going to fucking pants.
They make balls.
Yeah,
they do.
They do.
I mean they make neoprene balls or
something that,
let's say you have little balls are big
balls and you could listen if you get
anything.
She's switching to real patois.
We could change around just because,
you know,
I think that I like fucking Doris Day
music and one day I want to be a woman.
It just,
I think that's a little bit more than
that.
I think that it's just a little bit
fucking more than that.
Yeah,
it's.
I'm not against it.
I don't know.
The guy who does a is a,
is a guy that lives in Colorado.
The busiest guy look him up is a guy
that lives in southern Colorado and he
doesn't mind the weekends.
He's booked eight years in advance and
really he has a regular job during the
week.
I don't want to quote it.
We've talked about this before.
You have to look it up.
It was on 60 minutes and then the
weekends he does the operations.
He's booked three years in advance,
I think during the week.
He's like a farmer or aphasia
assumptions.
Fucking crazy.
And on the weekends he cut your fucking
Dick off and puts that fucking monkey
that,
that chicken we met in Vegas with the
artificial turf and the fucking holes
that time.
Remember Riviera's member reviewing.
The security came and tapped.
As you're talking to a fucking Javier,
get confused and you know what,
if I have had a couple bumps in me,
I will let that thing suck.
My Dick wasn't that bad without official
turf monkey and shit.
You Finger Bang that in the whole
lighter.
Julie's said Jodi and said,
it looks like a bat.
What?
Oh my God.
It was the ugliest fucking thing you had
ever seen and it just freaked you out.
Like you just don't want to eat no more
like you didn't want to drink like none.
It was going to take away the pain and
they're much better at doing it now.
Apparently now they can construct a
pretty realistic looking vagina.
The point where it really fucks people
up.
We'll fucking fucking cups with a vagina
on it will fucking cups.
Flashlight is a cup with a fucking
vagina on it that you know,
whatever feels it doesn't go cocktails.
You don't know what you're fucking
dude's some dudes.
Men have no problem like having sex with
a,
a.
he's like a girl that used to be a guy
as long as it's a girl now she's a guy.
Girl.
Man,
she's a girl,
man,
I ain't got no problem with that.
Like there's dudes that will tell you
they have no problem with that.
They think that it's a girl,
but there's other dudes just like,
listen,
when you're drunk and it's four in the
fucking morning,
alright,
and you're driving on Santa Monica and
you haven't gotten your Dick Sucked and
60,
70,
80 days.
All right.
And you're driving,
you're fucked up and you got to gram a
blow in your pocket.
That chick with the blonde hair becomes
whatever you want it.
You pull over and do a couple lines and
had that fucking monster suction pipe.
Why?
There's no,
it's happening.
I know it's happened.
It's had no,
I'm just going for broke tonight and
fuck it.
And after she sucked your Dick,
you just make a quick fucking turn and
throw out of the car and you drive home
and hope there's no fucking satellites
around taking cameras.
What are you going to do?
What the fuck are you going to do?
Some dudes,
it becomes a utility thing.
It's like you can't get rid of this
stuff.
Absolutely.
I bet that this guys out there that is
so fucking crazy on it that they don't
even care until they come and it's like
anything else.
How many times have you started whacking
off and all the sudden you start
thinking of women that think those suck
your Dick,
but after you crack that nut,
you just put your phone down.
I already cracked my neck.
I'm going to put up with that crazy bits
talking nonsense.
You know what I'm saying?
I just,
I just wiped myself off the debt deal.
I need this shit.
You're projecting.
It's true.
I would never come if I don't come in in
a certain amount of time that I'm not
going to go to a tranny tranny.
Just looking at a training makes me
sick.
Like when you make that right turn.
I'm fucking Santa Monica and you go up
highland or Libretto.
The best is if you get up early in the
morning,
like you have to go somewhere to the
airport and you take love bread down
five in the morning,
right?
Man,
I don't think they'll have brand Santa
Monica.
There's 20 of them and let me tell you
something.
I'm here to tell you a man that I am.
I don't.
You can't fucking tell to you pulled
over it until you pull over and look at
them.
You don't know,
and by that time you're 50 percent.
There was a dude who was an Iraqi vet,
picked up a hooker,
came back from Iraq,
hooker,
blows them,
finds out the hookers or guy,
shoot some cops,
see him,
dumped the body out of his car.
High speed chase that go to the desert.
He jumps out of the car with the gun
suicide by cop.
Wow.
Oh,
because he couldn't deal with the fact
that the dude sucked his dick.
So you had to kill the guy.
If he just let that guy go and laughed
it off.
What a fucking story.
Who would have been a great story?
It was one of us.
You can be at parties and be like,
tell him about that time that sucked
your Dick.
All right,
come on over.
I'm going to just tell it.
I'll tie the bitch up and call you guys
and we'll do a podcast with him.
Nobody believe it.
Listen,
Joe Rogan.
Listen you.
You stopped.
You're at a bar.
You pick up a girl that you think you
bring it home.
You go between the legs and she's got a
nine inch fucking cock.
Let me,
because most of those trainees always
have the biggest fuck.
Tranny ain't going to have a two inch
Dick.
They always got a rope between their
fucking legs.
So you don't think right there when you
grabbed that laugh,
Joe Rogan.
No,
I'd be dangerous.
I'd felt like I was in danger because I
was like,
I got tricked.
I feel like I'm getting tricked and if
you get tricked and all of a sudden the
trick turns out to be a man.
That's a dangerous situation when you're
alone with a man.
So now you've got to wonder what the
fuck you gotta fight.
You gotta.
Find out if that person's violent.
You got to find out that person's
apologetic.
You got to find out if that person just
fucked up with a gun in your hand.
All of these things.
I'm going to find that I'm a fine.
It's upstairs.
I'll be ready.
I'm going to shove it up.
Your rest.
I'm going to come back with that nine
millimeter at gunpoint.
You miserable cock.
Sucker.
Gumby the fucking truth.
How long have you been doing this?
Something.
We've got to do something here.
We just can't let you just.
You're not going to laugh it off.
It's crazy.
Would shoot him.
You think you'd tell them something?
I got to kick him in the stomach.
I got to do something.
Something's getting a beating.
We got to do something.
I'm calling my friends fluffed up.
I fucked up.
I picked up this chicken.
Grab a pussy in it.
She had a bigger Dick than me.
What do I do in the morning?
Monica Boulevard.
Would you shoot him if he had the gun on
you guys succeed?
Do it.
Would it be just get the fuck out of my
car or would it be bad?
Now you threw money at car.
Think of that feeling you're going to
have.
That has to be the worst feeling you're
going to get back in your car.
You're going to crash your car against
the fucking wall,
the one 90,
because you can't believe this just
happened to you.
Whenever you do five minutes after you
find that this person is.
It's legal.
I can sell that in court.
I could sell that and caught a lumps.
Let's break it down.
Forget the turn.
This is dog and a man.
You ever want to crack a fucking nut?
Late night and a blind heels.
She stuck shit.
Dick and you go for that monkey.
There's a two foot fucking cock.
There's three minutes of blackout time
right there.
Let's get a little conference.
The attorneys,
how long did he do?
Did he bring her home and shoot shooter?
If you shoot it within four or five
minutes,
this temporary insanity.
Think of water is going to feel like
you're right.
I don't know if he could call a
temporary insanity.
You wouldn't get.
You wouldn't get life.
You don't know that.
It means it might've.
It might've been some sort of an assault
situation,
so the car as well.
We don't know when he confronted them.
It could have been that the guy attacked
him first and then he got pulled his gun
out.
I mean,
he's probably freaked.
Well,
who the fuck knows?
We're just totally SPEC.
I'll tell you.
That was a soldier and Iraqi soldier
came back.
I mean all this guy had to do was pull
over and tell the cops,
well first let me talk to you.
What happened?
Let me tell you what really happened to
us.
I'm a little horn in my country and some
guy just suck my dick and I shot him.
What do you think?
We're going to let this go.
Still get some.
They don't ever let it go.
When someone shoots somebody listening,
you get to good cops in the right mood.
One of them just got,
the other one's got a brother who's gay
and you don't like thanksgiving.
You know what I'm saying?
And also what some guy sucked your Dick.
We feel for you.
Get back in the car.
We'll just wrap this up.
Let somebody find.
I think a guy would.
That might've happened in the sixties,
but nowadays,
well now,
because you got the.
Yes.
Yeah.
Back in the day,
cops were the only ones that were able
to talk
and make a decision.
Right then they can be.
Yeah,
they could be in the car with a little,
you know,
one out of 12,
1:00
AM 12,
and we're closing a suspect.
Now you've got cameras.
You can't do nothing,
but still.
Joe,
let me talk to you on this side.
It's a quarter to 12.
We've got this Puerto Rican chick that
wants to suck my dick.
She likes when I come over with my gun
holster around.
This guy just killed the training.
We've got no paperwork here.
Is that what it is?
Sure.
That's.
You know,
he doesn't matter,
Joe.
You still have to account for a murder.
That's the problem with your theory,
but he'll have to account for a guy was
shot a guy.
Understand this.
You have a suspect that have it all
wrapped up.
Are you thinking of with them and tell
the court the truth.
You get off of involuntary man's want to
do six years.
They cut that in half.
You're out of that and a couple fucking
months really,
and you got to shoot somebody and have
some fun and get your degree three years
to shoot somebody and get your Dick
sucked.
Let's a lot of fun.
That shoots and the smell.
The gunpowder in prison food was really
bad.
Oh,
it's terrible.
But you've got a good attorney and
negotiate it down.
Do you remember cafeteria food like in
college or high school?
It's just like horrible.
Fucking horrible.
It's like a different.
It's like Mcdonald's fit prison.
Have you seen this new bill they're
trying to pass now.
That would make make it possible to
strip anybody have citizenship if they a
proposed a threat to America.
They're American citizens.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
It snuck in.
Got It.
Yeah.
So what are you going to take it back
to?
It's like the keep.
I don't know.
They're going to kick you out of the
country.
They keep coming up with crazier and
crazier fucking things.
It's like this is the year of like total
complete control.
Like they're trying to control the
Internet,
that trying to control this national
defense authorization act.
They're trying Sopa and Pipa,
all this different shit that's going on.
It's like the control is getting tighter
and tighter and tighter and when you
hear shit like this,
like they want to be able to strip
people of their citizenship like what
the fuck?
Like Mexico or somewhere that'll take
you.
I mean there's a few countries that will
just take.
Yeah,
that seems like illegal.
Like worldwide.
It's possible.
This is the strangest time in my life
of,
of like watching the government and
watching all these people scrambled to
try to get into position.
Like this is a weird time,
man.
This,
this feels so bizarre.
I never thought I would see something
like that.
Like someone writing something down like
that,
like that.
You should be able to have the power to
kick people out of the country if
somehow or another they do something to
harm America,
but that's,
you know how ridiculous that is.
No one's harming America.
They're coming up all these fucking
crazy laws and the ability to detain
people,
but what is really happening here?
Nothing.
Nothing's happening in America.
The only thing that's happening is that
people are saying they're not happy with
the current government.
That's the only action that's happening
in the whole country.
It's not like there's some fucking crazy
thing going on where we're being
constantly attacked by terrorists and we
have to figure out how to defend
ourselves and an ever changing world.
Now there's fucking terror attacks
and I don't say they're.
They're catching them all.
I don't really think there's that many
terrorists out there.
people that fucking hate us and I think
that number would be substantially less
if we weren't occupying another fucking
countries,
but the bottom line is they're coming up
with all these,
these does this,
these laws that are set up to control us
and to shackle us,
to put us down in there protecting us
from what these laws are for what?
Where is this threat?
Where's this threat in our country that
you need to create these laws will.
The only threat is to the power that be.
That's the only threat.
The powers that be are the only ones who
are being threatened.
That's it.
It's not like we have to worry about
terrorist attacks,
you know?
That's a fucking.
That's a bullshit thing,
man.
There's not that many fucking
terrorists.
There's not that many.
Yeah,
there are some and yeah,
there are plots and yes,
some are legit,
but did the laws that they're coming up
with band,
they're not doing this to protect us
from terrorism.
They're doing this to make it harder for
people to get up and protest.
That's what the fuck they're doing.
It says this a spooky,
spooky time to watch this shit go down.
It's like this is everything.
They warned us about the founding
fathers.
This is.
This is everything.
Benjamin Franklin said,
this is bizarre.
It's like they predicted it.
They predicted that one day there would
become a point of ultimate corruption.
You have to do everything you can and
keep these pieces in place in order to
avoid that.
Ultimately
corruption is communist.
To read deep communism is government
isn't three d water,
like they come on your computers posts
that pull you over and take your fucking
asked you for an id and I understand
your protectiveness,
but again,
protecting us from how much money you
got.
Middle America running fucking scared
would see in the media running scared,
you know,
and,
and they don't know,
they really don't fucking know that.
They're scaring us into giving us us
giving up our rights.
Yeah.
They want us to do,
give us our fucking rights by scaring
us.
Well,
if you don't let me fuck an x ray,
you'll,
we can't catch a fucking whatever.
If you know,
it's always something.
These fall laws,
it's always fucking something every
week.
Well,
you know,
there's a lot of people that believe
that the government would have tried
some sort of a false flag event.
You know,
the false flag event is an event that
like they'll do something on purpose in
order to get us to realize,
whoa,
there's a threat we need to like beef up
the law.
And that's like shit that they've pulled
since the beginning of time.
But there's a lot of people that don't
believe they can do that today.
They think that it's too easy.
The access to information is just too
easy to spread and that with the
Internet it's so difficult to control
things.
They don't think they could do it.
What happened to the occupy movement?
I didn't believe I was still going on
when everyone,
olive garden they occupy or where the
fuck are these people?
Where the fuck are they protesting
against American airline with a $20
dollar luggages when people,
American Airlines,
everybody's paying the 20 foot of
luggage were all these.
I don't think money would have occupied.
That's back Merrigan airline luggage
thing I can on every day for that fly
southwest or I fucking loved it.
I thought to take.
For me,
I think that all we got to do is bring
pathways.
Corporations back to the United States.
I don't care if you want to open up
something of what.
You got to open up one here too.
You've got to pay taxes for this one and
then do whatever the fuck you want in
Beijing with Hindus or whatever the fuck
you want to do.
And that's what's killed Middle America.
They've left Pittsburgh.
There's no more manufacturing.
Well,
that's what I,
that's what I want back.
You know,
we can have some fucking job.
We've talked about this before,
but like ipods,
like a or a,
you know,
an iphone.
I would pay,
I would pay like double the amount of
money for a Karma free iphone.
There was more,
you know,
that American workers is what it would
cost.
Yeah,
I heard that.
But you know,
here are the,
here's the problem with that logic,
the minerals,
the minerals to make those phones.
You have to get an Africa and you've
seen how they get those minerals.
Man,
that's,
that's at the end of the most
complicated shit that we have.
Technology at its root is a kid in
Africa working in a fucking mind,
pulling shit out of the ground with a
piece of metal and a stick.
I mean,
it's,
it's as,
as base as you can get,
child fucking slavery in Africa,
making,
extracting minerals is super common.
You know,
it's,
you know,
they had that advice special.
Well they did on it when they went to
the Congo and watch these guys and it's
um,
it's,
it's weird to think that that's the only
way you could do that.
The only way you can get those minerals
is you've got to go there.
That's where they're at.
But,
and you know,
their,
their sense of I want to have kids just
so I have them doing chores because I
don't want to have a made in my house.
But it seems like when I was young I had
to like clean the living room.
Went to once a time.
And that's kind of like having your kid
being a child labor,
you know,
like you're making them clean your house
chores,
children,
responsibility rooms,
scrub bathrooms because kids have to
have responsibility,
learn to contribute.
I am happy my parents made me do chores
because it taught me how to work hard.
Father taught me how to just hit it off
and fucking work hard.
I think my parents took advantage of me
and I was mowing lawns and shit and then
I'm like,
looking back on man,
I need that in my life right now.
I need to have kids just to clean this
place up because I'm tired of doing it.
I'm not sure how the fuck that works
with child labor in Africa on phones.
I'm not sure how you made that
connection because it's like making kids
work.
Like you can kiss world of your own
body.
His work helping out and contributing it
at home is not working.
My mother used it.
It's fucked up man.
What's up?
My mother used to work.
Make me fucking.
I might stop the empty
the tampon things.
Lindemann's fucking bathroom at my
mother's bar when I was sick and put ice
cubes in the fucking urinals and fucking
stuck to the ice cube.
So it doesn't splatter back at you or is
it just to make clay gamed it.
My Dad was an architect so most of my
jobs and I got summer jobs and shit.
It was always on construction sites,
so I've worked like real jobs.
I had some real construction jobs and
especially,
you know,
after I graduated I had some that went
through the winter.
We worked outside in the winter.
Once you know,
it's no,
those are real jobs.
Those are my best days in Colorado.
Flat roofs back.
I'm in the dead of the winter.
One day I took a shit in a bag and
crunched it up and gave it to one of the
workers and told them it was a brown.
Like 10 minutes later he's like,
this brown.
It smells like shit.
We're fucking.
I used to be a fucking roof and
estimating ruth.
When I got out of prison,
I was in the halfway house.
I was an estimator for,
but I started out as a fucking bloating
the roofs in boulder,
Colorado in January and snow and you got
to get up there and shovel the snow.
Then cut it and throw it in and then.
Aw,
Geez.
We used to build Igloos to fucking put
rubber down on the roofs.
That's fucking crazy.
Well,
they work.
That's the thing about you still build
Igloos.
What do you mean?
Right,
so let's say you have to lay down a 40
squares of rubber that day with
ballasted with rocks.
We would shovel the roof at after the
fucking shoveling.
We laid the insulation down,
but it was snowing,
so three labors will be cutting the roof
and the other three were building poles
with a cover so the snow wouldn't land
on the insulation so we'd have to build
shit when it's.
No,
it was like a New Jersey and New York
City,
which is the biggest metropolitan city.
They get six inches of snow in the city
closes down.
I thought he was like blocking ice and
making like Colorado.
They get a foot of snow and you're at
work at eight.
Oh,
one second.
Another day of business.
You can't say,
well my bus came late because it didn't
come late.
Bitch.
That motherfucker came on time.
They'd been driving in the snow for 20
years.
There's no.
I'm 10 minutes late because there was
snow in Colorado.
It ever is.
He knows really impressive.
We were in Montreal in December and it
was cold as fuck,
but man,
that airport was smooth there.
De Icing.
They had that shit down pat.
Then model allowing,
plowing the.
They were plowing the runways and
cleaning everything needed runway.
Yeah.
So they just really fucking amazing.
Amazing.
Yeah.
They avoid a lot of bullshit.
They plan well for the,
for the cold up there.
It's an.
Yeah,
they do in Colorado too.
They really do.
In the suburbs,
you like,
it snowed a foot and the fucking guy
came by with the plow and he did it.
It's over.
It's over in the bigger cities,
like it snows in three days,
you know,
fucking crazy shit isn't me.
Hearing about like the mountains getting
like seven feet,
like every now and then they'll get a
snow dog,
but seven feet of snow will fall on the.
I don't think people even understand
what the fuck that means.
I've prepared.
If you're not going anywhere,
you're not going anywhere for a week.
At least.
I hit the.
I hit the 1983.
If you could get a minute.
I hit the 1983 blizzard,
which was 24 days in a row of snow,
anywhere from two inches to two feet,
but it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
It was snow every day.
So you pretty much went home and you
know,
got up to Thanksgiving blizzard.
Oh Ha.
That's what Colorado is known for.
They say that Colorado gets blizzard.
It's always like around Thanksgiving or
Halloween.
One or the other.
The other one of the early.
Just to remind you,
bitch put away the,
you know what I'm saying?
Like don't get too comfortable with your
shorts and itchy.
Like in September,
my sister was born in the blizzard of
[inaudible] 78 in Ohio and they had to
take a helicopter,
had to go to my parents' house and pick
her up my mom up to have to really.
Holy Shit.
How much was that fucking helicopter
ride?
One of the biggest snow storms to ever
hit a major city in the u.
The thanksgiving blizzard.
Nineteen 83.
Cairo.
Yeah.
Particular Blizzard just wanted a whole
series of storms and blew through the
country over a two week period.
So something happened in like a weather
pattern got stuck over there or
something.
Oh,
it was it Joe Rogan and it wasn't.
I remember looking at the sky,
how the sky looked like.
You could still see the moon and the
fucking morning,
like at five in the morning and you
could still see the moon and the sun's
coming out the same time with that haze.
It's just fucking beautiful mountain.
How long did it take before people could
move around?
Twenty minutes.
No,
no,
no.
After the blizzard.
Like how long before people could drive
around 20 minutes.
No,
come on Bro.
It's Colorado,
you know,
seven feet of snow.
How the fuck?
Oh,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's snowing and people live in their
life.
You know what I'm saying?
They're just known and it's adding up
and you're still living your life.
You're like,
well,
we've got a foot of snow and sudden you
go in,
you look out at midnight,
honey,
I got to put my shoes on.
I had to go back out there and shovel.
And you know,
it was one of those that I've read that
they've gotten seven feet of snow in
some areas,
but my brain won't let me believe that
my brain,
my brain is going shut up.
That's over a car.
Well,
that's seven fucking feet.
Seven feet of snow.
It's not real.
That's fun.
Is the most the deepest snow that has
ever been recorded?
Like the deepest snow for.
Let's find out what is the deepest.
I don't think it's here either.
Would you think might be in the United
States?
The most amount of snowfall in the
morning?
Yeah.
I don't think it would be in the United
States somewhere.
What's the deepest snow fall in the
United States?
Oh Shit.
It's a race between typing 19,
93.
Storm of the century.
The total snowfall.
Twelve feet.
Oh my God.
What?
Twelve point nine slash 10 feet.
Hold on.
It's like a storm of the century.
90 three superstar.
But the
buzzard,
1993,
the east coast,
North America,
blah,
blah blah blah,
uh,
killed.
Three hundred and 10 people.
What is the most snow and a storm ever
bought whole?
I loved the navy.
Threes is Christ snowdrifts are as high
as 35 fee and that's a drift.
You see some wild shit living up there
and spin off a Ajax.
You see some fucking drips.
You know I'm going to Riverton,
Wyoming and all that.
Like my buddies used to jump off a
helicopter and land in the snow and
they'd say that it had to be 20 feet of
fucking snow onto them.
You imagine that just jumping on a
helicopter 20 feet and landing.
It's snowy.
Oppose that James Bond Shit.
That's crazy.
Crazy shit.
Take you up there with.
There's no lifts.
There's no.
Oh my God.
Yes.
And you just go down and you don't know
what time do you those videos,
whatever.
I watched those videos,
those extreme sports videos of guys
jumping out of helicopters are the
fucking snowboard and going down the
side of a mountain that's minus won't be
taken place on Avatar.
There might be this,
you might as well be doing some silver
surfer shit.
You know,
I can't even believe I'm sharing the
planet with you like you're a crazy
person.
You're doing like you're.
You live in the nuttiest suicide like,
oh,
I'm just having a massive confidence in
their ability to surf and ski and I
guess the rush of it is so spectacular.
They're willing to take the risk of
dying.
People die all the time.
People just.
Somebody just died the other day.
Girl.
Yeah,
she,
I think she was doing some crazy sort of
a jump though.
Our.
Yeah,
those are really dangerous men.
If you're fucking ski jumping,
you're flying through the air and you're
hoping you're going to land perfectly on
this fucking slope and everything's all
slippery.
Like Valentines,
we can ask when I was telling you that
that's one of the lower,
the lowest point of moistures India,
so people ski with Bikini's on February.
What they do is they build a ramp and
snowmass village.
People ski down with Bikinis and do a
loop de loop over a fucking pool
swimming pool and people do it all the
time and you're like,
oh my God.
Like I couldn't have.
Even I,
I was just happy skin going,
you know,
I'm like a green fucking blow up or
something.
I was just happy not jumping and shit
like that,
but sometimes I would ski and pick up
momentum and I just crashed just to stop
Joe Rogan.
That's how fast you go on those fucking
skis.
I'm telling you the truth.
I don't give a fuck what anybody tells
you.
When I first started skiing the first
season,
I wasn't too good at stopping.
I always do the plows and I would just
take our fucking ski lines.
I would just take him to fuck off
because I had no choice.
I would just put my head down and go in
there like,
fuck jerome bettis.
People get hurt.
That wouldn't hurt.
And that's tornado season.
My second season I started planning a
little better and I got better,
but this time.
So you pick them up some speed and
you're like,
Whoa,
wait a second.
Let's.
I would just fall.
Remember when it killed Sonny Bono,
man?
Yeah.
That was a fucking tree that.
That's.
That happens.
You just gained.
You hit something.
You Ski,
twist to the jungle one.
Oh Damn.
That's how you come up with the skill.
That was when I learned about coolness.
Does anybody ski with a helmet on?
I would.
What'd you?
Yeah.
I mean I used to ski with like a big
Michelin man out,
big nerf outfit.
Like that's when I learned about
coolness.
I taught coolness was being in New York
in the village and smoking a joint.
No,
no,
no.
When you go skiing and you get in that
fucking gambling,
there's six people and they looked like
your grandpa and all of a sudden
somebody comes over and goes,
do you mind if for a spark up a joint?
And you're like,
are you fucking so really the spark of
the Gondolas give you mushrooms are
joints.
You don't know who you.
People go skiing to the doctors and go,
look,
we can't get high in Minneapolis,
but we're going to get high and we go to
ask me will try and it would do and it
was doing mushrooms.
I spent as a kind of a crazy town.
It's very,
it's weird that there's so many rich
people that live in Aspen.
Like I remember being in Aspen going,
how are they affording all these houses?
Like these are just gigantic,
multi,
multimillion dollar houses all over the
place and the stores are all at the
highest end stores.
How many people actually live up there
though?
It all winter.
It's mostly winter.
A lot.
The summer's a fucking beautiful and
aspen and you got to remember,
this is the sick thing about aspen.
Visa are their second homes.
These are their winter homes.
They close them up and put a.
The Guy I house sat for,
it was the owner of the.
He was on the board of Tgi Friday and
this was one of his eight houses and he
would only use it one week a year.
Jesus.
And he wanted you to live in the house.
So when he came to town there was no
dilemmas guide.
Four bedrooms.
I undo the speedometer on his fucking
jeep.
I was living in Montana.
I Jacuzzi inside,
outside.
He had an apartment over the garage.
That's common,
right?
That people hire a coach,
hire a caretaker,
and all my job was 20 hours a month,
so it was either 20 hours of mowing the
lawn or 20 hours of shoveling snow or
both 20 and it was,
that's it.
I wasn't much and so what he would just
call you when he's coming into town,
you will call me and say I'm coming in
December 14th to the 28th and you would
just start cleaning it up and I would
clean up my side of the house and I had
everything stashed and says his side of
the house.
I had an office and inside of the House
and scales up there,
I had everything.
Really?
Yeah.
He had one,
two,
three,
five bedrooms and outside Jacuzzi inside
Jacuzzi.
And he had.
So even when he was there,
you were still staying there?
I would stay in the garage over the.
He had an apartment he built that was
beautiful cable.
Everything at so I would stay there and
then when he only for that one week and
then I was only a cat take off in his
bed,
I'd fucked up.
I've done everything in this fucking
house.
I had the keys to the cabinets because
what you do is you put all your stuff in
a particular cabinet and lock it.
So if you rent it out of your friends
come to visit,
they don't find what your shit.
Right.
That's what you do.
So.
But I had the keys to that so I'd make
my fucking.
He had pounds of elk and venison up
there.
Really,
you know,
he was a hunter up there so it was an
amazing fucking gate.
But that was part of his thing.
Use everything,
use everything.
I don't want to come to town and have
to,
you know,
I don't want the sink to be broken
because your trees.
Right,
right,
right.
He's like I need you in the house taking
a shower.
And he got,
you know,
at that time it was stated a fucking out
the house.
Yeah.
You have to live in it for 35 fall way
road.
I snorted more fucking blow and eight
more snatching that fucking house and I
seen some creepy.
I never been in there with a couple one
night and I like,
I met them at the bar,
like I knew her from the cheesecake and
they have the cheesecake store.
There wasn't a cheesecake factory.
It was 1984 and I invited them over and,
and,
and I went to change and she was naked
and I was like,
what the fuck is.
She goes,
what are you thinking?
My tits.
I remember we all went back into the
Jacuzzi and then at like five in the
morning,
he was a baker at a poll of fronts.
I don't know if they're still there and
he left.
They both left and then she called me
and said,
come get me.
And I went over,
picked her up,
brought her back to the Jacuzzi.
I had the weirdest fucking things happen
in Aspen.
The weirdest sex things.
That's a crazy fucking town because it's
like anywhere else.
When people come up there for a week,
they want to fucking suck.
You know?
People want to get lost and the people
that would kill up there were people
from Texas.
I will spend millions up there.
I went to one of those bars,
one of the local bars with one of the
agents when we had the,
the Aspen comedy festival.
I remember that when they hit the Hbo
Festival.
And uh,
I was with his agent and he goes,
you see these girls?
See that girl,
that girl,
that girl?
I go,
yeah,
he goes,
those are all hookers,
thousand and nine.
I was like,
what thousand dollars?
They just go to bars and like they just
wait and they're hookers like they come
into town.
Apparently he was saying that some of
them know,
like when during ski season that there's
a lot of wealthy men,
thousand and nine.
That's incredible.
So they come in and they like hunt and
this is their hunting ground.
That's amazing.
They got a job on the lift to the
immediate sugar daddy and then it's all
low really?
Or they just go up there to hookup and
Aspen.
It's amazing.
There's so much dough up and there's so
many crazy.
I remember going up there when I talked
to get there,
I left and I left New York City and the
peak of New York City and I went to
Aspen.
They weren't missing a beat.
There was a bar named Patty bugattis
that had a swimming pool in the middle,
was hard with the swim right in the
middle.
That's awesome.
So you could swim while you were
drinking.
Get coked up people and they with their
clothes.
Makeup.
This was asking in 83.
[inaudible] 83.
I asked him was the cocaine capital of
the country because there was so much
money up.
That's where Miami vice was in Glen Fry
and you creek and Sidney Poitier.
Michael Douglas.
You just seen people come in.
Elizabeth Tale.
I seen a.
what's the name once the flying nun,
that bad ass bitch.
That chick that was hanging out with
burt reynolds for awhile.
Oh,
sally.
Sally,
finance bitch.
At that time with her brown and a
metcon,
Charles Bronson was up there running
shit for awhile.
When I first moved to Aspen,
they had Katie la was only one channel
and all they did was play Mr.
Majestic,
isn't it hard to get into aspen though?
Like the flying isn't a difficult
flight.
Well they don't land in there at night
after 8:00
or something.
They got strict rules.
But now you could fly to aspen from la
direct real.
In the old days it was just Denver and
Colorado Springs or not.
And if you,
like I told you,
if you fly into aspen as you're flying
over woody creek,
there's a guy that dumped his wife that
was a stewardess.
So he painted a finger on his roof.
So when you fly over asking the daytime,
there's always a roof the fucking finger
on it because his wife was a stewardess
for one of the airlines.
Woody creek is a very.
I seen,
I remember being a kid and a Conoco on,
at the,
uh,
old snowmass border.
There was a conical that the guys were
from New York and when you went into
that New York time and Colorado time.
But I know that seeing Kurt Ruffling
Goldie Hawn with those fucking kids
being kids,
like I didn't know.
I didn't know she was the girl from
fucking.
I didn't know she was going to be a
star.
There were kids at Conoco and that
Conoco see at that time in Colorado it
was all retired drug dealers.
Right.
So the feds were up there big time.
So in old snowmass they had this drug
dealer so the feds fucking put cameras
around his house,
but they didn't know how to do with
that.
So it came up on people's Cable TV.
So people on cable going,
hey bro,
you're on Channel Four,
you know you're cooking eggs,
aren't you?
And he's like,
how do you know?
He sued the government.
Wow.
Full fucking millions for an.
I mean Aspen's got some wild fucking
shit.
There's a guy look him up,
Steven Gray Ball,
he got caught with $8,000,000.
Joe Rogan,
December of 83,
December of 84.
He was 30 days away from staying,
standing drop and they blew them up with
a pipe bomb at the Aspen club when he
was working out.
And that was the only night he didn't
pay somebody that started his fucking
car.
They blew them up with a fucking pipe
bomb in the city of Aspen.
Which an 83,
there wasn't even a fucking Spanish
person up there.
It was just nice white people.
Jesus Christ,
his first sentence,
despite its reputation as a city that
never sleeps,
thanks to the copious consumption of
chemical stimulants,
aspen has seen relatively few large
scale drug busts.
Wow.
So they're just doing drugs up in Aspen.
This is a fucking terrible comments.
You come in with the government,
you come and listen to fucking jail and
aspen don't got a kitchen.
That's the only on the country that
don't have a kitchen.
They get that food catered.
So you get muffins for breakfast and tea
and really?
Yeah.
That's why bundy escaped from there.
How do you think these people fucking
escape from there?
What?
They use the phone and climbed the
fucking window.
Aspen,
Colorado.
When I was there,
some guy shot a guy with a machine gun
and a coke party shot.
I'm going to machine gun.
They had the guy fishing.
They take good a fishing trips in the
summer down there.
Fucking roaring fork thing.
They take your fish and they take the
prisoners.
I went to prison.
The biggest thing I wanted to go to the
rifle because they gave you a job as a
lifeguard in the city,
so they use the prisoners,
is lifeguards and they gave you a job in
the movie theater in rifle.
I ended up at Camp George West,
but I really wanted to go to rifle,
which is on the other side of the hill.
Asman.
It's like an hour for Massman,
but in the wintertime they had worked
for because you took over the city that
prisoners,
but it's fucking aspen has no fucking
kitchen,
my friend.
That's ridiculous.
And they still get food catered for
them.
What is there like a lot of shit out
there though.
It just.
This is sort of when I give you that
fact is people twitted me right now
going,
Joe,
you an asshole.
I'm telling you in 1983,
if you look at Colorado was the cocaine
capital of the country because
Colorado's right in the middle of the
country.
At that time,
Mexico,
we weren't using Mexico,
so it was Miami and everything got
shipped to Colorado and from Colorado
went to Minneapolis,
Seattle,
California,
blah,
blah.
Everybody's waiting for something in
California.
Everybody's waiting for you.
In California and Colorado.
It's a bunch of fucking guys.
Would horses at the airport helping you
carry the coconut to the plane?
Can I help you with that?
They're helping you.
It's a very mystique type of fucking
city.
At the top of this.
It's Glenwood Springs.
Snowmass village.
Woody Creek and asked and sits on the
fucking top.
Dude.
This is the whole story.
Nineteen eight.
The grable case.
They were.
Yeah.
They didn't tell us about how he was
blown up and above a bomb placed in a
borrowed car that he drove to the Aspen
Club for a tennis.
What the fuck you think you're dealing
with here?
Joy.
Bananas.
I'll drop it on and if and if I'm right,
it was December twelfth or December
something.
December 1980.
Fuck you think you're dealing with it?
A bomb in a borrowed car as he drove to
the Aspen Club for a tennis match.
Could you imagine all this fucking Aspen
Heights,
but listen to me showing up at their
tennis outfits on and Mercedes and
pulling into the driveway and his
fucking car blows up.
I listened to these numbers.
He was making $6 million every six
weeks.
After two or three years he was making
so much money.
He was a Jewish kid that went to Miami,
University of Miami to get a degree and
ended up hanging out with Cubans and
Colombians and that was it.
They made him a white guy.
They just said,
you're going to control the west coast.
And he was making 6 million every six
weeks.
Couldn't even can cleanse it fast enough
so he would come into your restaurant
and go,
Joe Rogan,
I'm going to give you 25,000
cash.
Call me when it's over.
So he would go to every restaurant in
this area and give him 25 grand and go
do me a favor.
Call me when it's over.
So I'm just going to come in and eat
every day.
Just tell me when they're 25 grand and
the quicker the better.
Like if I come in here for three
hotdogs,
told me the 25 is gone,
you're doing me a favor.
So when they busted him,
they just didn't bust him.
If you read the story that went to these
businesses,
you know that there's a movie that they
did years later.
That was his story where he had safe set
all the restaurants where you would come
to your restaurant.
I'm going to give you 25 grand a month.
They usually tell me when it's over,
but I'm going to put a safe in the back.
And he started putting some.
When the feds came up there,
they found a million,
2 million.
All these things.
My come to Denver,
he couldn't even wash the money fast
enough.
They took them to Denver and Denver.
The feds go,
go back to the fucking house because
there's still another 10 million that we
haven't found.
We've been listening to him.
So they went back to the house,
couldn't find it,
couldn't find it.
He had hidden in a garbage can.
Fill with leaves outside.
How the feds got them,
what they were gone and taken his
garbage and they were looking at his
paperwork so the feds will come every
morning and take his garbage and look at
the figures he would do.
They did it from the scrapping.
So all the little figures you do a rip
up that all that Shit.
That's how they nailed them.
So they waited a fucking year til he was
30 days away from sentencing in this
beautiful white suburban town above
Aspen,
Colorado.
And on a Sunday night they fucking blew
him up in a rented car.
Why you waiting?
He had a borrowed car because at that
point he had eight cars in his garage.
Like he had cars everywhere.
Couldn't trust any of them.
He couldn't trust any of them.
They knew.
He knew that the,
the,
the Colombians weren't going to take it
whether he talked to not.
Why take the chance we're going to kill
him.
So he had bodyguards and I didn't.
He didn't know that they put a fucking
pipe bomb on them.
That was Miami vice type shit.
He went to Schottische car and he almost
lived.
But the pipe went up through his fucking
ass and he almost bled to death.
Yeah.
The pipe bomb went through him or
something.
Something weird.
He bled out or something.
He could have lived very interesting.
Aspen,
Colorado.
Very interesting place.
Jesus Christ.
That's hilarious.
Well,
whenever you have drugs,
you got to have violence.
Whenever you have people buying,
buying massive amounts of coke or
whatever the fuck they is it coke up
there.
This is where it gets better.
He never seen it.
What do you mean?
He moved so much blow.
He never even seen it.
He didn't see the glow.
He would go to the bank and get $500
worth of quarters a day.
His whole day was just getting caught
and they would drive three hours to a
payphone and do all his business from a
payphone.
Really?
He never waited.
He never seen it.
He never touched it.
He just moved it.
Go to Minneapolis,
go to la,
go to New Mexico.
Jesus is the center,
so he did it all from payphones,
everything.
Everything was from a payphone.
$500 a day and they were watching them
at the bank.
They were watching them.
They will want,
you know,
how big is asking you fight the whole
fucking town from housing that's amid
seven blocks or something.
They blocked Galena street.
Main Street.
You don't have much up there.
Are very big and he wasn't sanded up
there.
It wasn't like he was at bars at night.
No,
the guy was just.
That's just where he was.
He was just moving it across the
country.
Very interesting fucking story about.
That's a hell of a network you put
together to be able to accomplish that.
One of the first guys ever Jewish guy.
What would it be like of cocaine?
Was legal and knowing him knowing would
have been super right.
I'm the only one here that hasn't done
it very bad.
Very bad.
If they want to legalize that shit,
people go to pharmacies and shit.
It's just.
And it's.
And it's a creepy thing when you're
doing it and that's even creepier when
you're not doing it.
Yeah.
You know when you see it now you're
like,
wow,
is that how creepy guy was?
Obvious Rv,
somebody told me that the weed store
that they went to a party yesterday and
obviously the kitten didn't know it was
not a cold party because they went to a
football thing and the kid.
I'm like,
isn't that weird?
When one person is doing it,
they stick out that that's a weird
feeling when you're talking to a dude in
there coked up and they had.
They give off that weird unpredictable
energy like,
well I've got to get away from this guy.
I can't even read this motherfucker.
I don't know what he's doing and it's
just they just,
they come off off shifty looking around
a lot and can't shut the fuck up.
Constantly yapping.
It's tough.
Fucking afternoon.
When you were talking about the largest
snowfall,
did you hear what the actual one is and
this is ridiculous.
It's a hundred and 41 feet in more than
five days.
What?
Where's this?
And it was in Alaska.
Christ.
How's that?
Even possible.
So what happens that just like covers
the house and that's it.
You Die,
you die because no left.
You're attracting like Tom and Jerry
style where your windows shoveled out
away quick enough.
Yeah.
What happens?
You Die.
Yeah.
You pretty much lived off of whatever
was in her house,
I guess.
Yeah,
but even then you don't have any air
were where's your air coming in?
You've got to get air.
You have to make like a pipe using
sticks and then all that snow melts.
It's going to be a fucking river that's
going to wash your house away.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Unless you start eating it.
Maybe it was in a really rural area
where nobody lives.
Maybe that's why it's their subjects to
such giant snow dumps and they just had
20 feet like last week or so feet.
God Damn Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
There's some spots in this world that
are really hazardous.
You could deal with some shit.
That's the one thing.
You live in California for a little
while.
People completely forget.
They completely forget that there's
nature to consider like everybody's been
freaking out these last couple of days.
The reason why this podcast started late
is because some truck flipped over on
the highway because nobody knows how to
drive in the rain when it gets wet.
It's wet here and everybody just spazzes
out and on top of it,
the road is greasy as fuck because of
the fact that it doesn't rain very often
when it does rain,
it brings up all that oil from people's
cars and tires and all that and all the
shit that's on the car that everyone has
dirty cars or have film on the car
that's,
you know,
whatever rinses off as well.
Yeah.
Wax and all kinds of other gem
challenged chem trails.
Uh,
but there were so,
so,
you know,
I saw God lose it last night and I was
right behind him.
He's got the here at 4:15
and it's a 25 minute ride from my house.
I left at 3:00
on the clock as I was leaving and it was
slow the whole way.
And then as I got closer to seeing the
helicopters,
helicopters don't show for a little
accident.
They show for something heavy duty.
So it's a weird place.
There's too many of us men,
there's too many fucking people living
in one place,
so all we need is one thing to go wrong.
I tell you,
man,
when I was in Ohio though,
I don't give a shit because right now
it's going to be 90 degrees Thursday and
that that's worth it to me one way or
here?
No,
here 90.
I'm fucking Thursday.
Yeah.
I like people on the east coast right
now.
They call me and go,
you're 65 today.
Tomorrow Bitch.
February is next month.
Motherfucker call me February 15th when
you fucking Bikini on February 15th.
Pocket comedy.
Valentine's Day.
It's definitely harder to live in a
place like that.
It makes it just makes life harder.
But Minneapolis this week,
he's crazy.
He's going to that house and his
gangster,
all that he's doing.
He's doing a fucking scavenger hunt in
the mall with.
With,
with.
I'm going to get a little piece of
banana.
Prayerful bump.
That shit.
I'm going to open it up.
They don't play.
They're not the same.
Minnesota.
They'll throw you in jail right next to
Jesse.
Fucking Ventura.
Stop eating edibles because that fucking
surgery.
Yeah,
you have to stop eating it because it
just dog.
I got.
I fainted from reading the fucking
paperwork.
I fainted from reading.
We've discussed this before.
The needles or the blood.
Really?
I got to the fucking statured will.
The sutures will include sutures that
he's going to put sutures in my knee.
I fainted coming out from under my
titties.
You know,
you got lucky.
So I said,
you know what?
I think I had an edible that day to last
week.
I smoked a little piece of hash and I
read fucking.
I went online just to prepare for
surgery and I thought it would tell me
what vitamins to take and I'm reading
about this arthroscopic surgery and I
went fucking down on my fucking office.
What exactly are they saying is wrong
with your knee?
Meniscus tear,
a little bit of arthritis and a little
system.
The meniscus tearing.
So they're going to extract the system.
Then they're going to clean up the Nunez
case.
Yeah.
That's not too bad.
That's like six weeks and you're pretty
close to 100 percent.
You know,
I uh,
I waited,
I waited six weeks,
last time I did that and then was
training six weeks later by Google
swimming right afterwards just to bike
is really good.
Swimming is.
Swimming is decent cook too.
But what I like about a bike is that
it's stationary,
it's constant.
You don't have to worry about side to
side motion and you're just,
you can just do it at a light pace where
you're stimulating the tendons and the
ligaments and the muscle tissue,
but you're not really taxing the knee
now.
So you don't do it hard.
It's basically your five minutes.
Not even.
Don't even start with dying,
man.
Start with.
I've been doing a 45 on our load now.
Oh,
before I'm just doing everything in
order.
That's good.
You should get one of these.
What is fitbit?
You'll become addicted to it.
It attracted.
We talked about
this on the podcast today with most
people will know though,
because we talked about it on the desk.
Squad one.
Oh yeah.
So what it is,
it's this thing that you clip on and it
automatically tracks how many steps you
make.
How many stairs you walk?
Uh,
it tracks,
you know,
just like it's Bert Kreischer told us
about it.
Right.
He was the one who,
he's the one that told us about it on
the Ice House chronicles and uh,
so it's really neat is that it has like
a thing in it that you could also wear
when you sleep,
so it detects whenever you wake up and
so then it adds up how long you're
actually sleeping every night.
And you'll be surprised.
You think like,
oh I got like 10 hours sleep when in
reality you didn't like half the time
you were still awake or you would wake
up and it's based on,
you know,
it detects like your heartbeat it
detects,
has a gyro stick open it or whatever the
fuck it's called,
where.
So it tells you,
it knows when you're walking and all the
amazing.
Yeah.
And then wirelessly broadcasts to this
website and it shows you in graphs like,
like how much you did and stuff.
And you try to,
the more you use it,
the more you are like a game,
you try to beat it.
It's like twitter addictive,
like it's really interesting and I like
I just became friends on Bruckner
Chrysler's a a thing that it's like
having a new facebook where it just
tracks your,
your shit every night and I just did
like a big credible.
Yeah,
I did a little review it on that desk.
Squad dot TV and nurse links to buy.
I'll tell you something,
bro.
That new sleep apnea machine,
they gave me the other one fucked up
that time to give me a new one where I
thought the old one was good.
This new one.
I can take the card out,
put it into my computer and I could tell
you what nights I drank alcohol.
I don't drink alcohol.
I can tell you that what nights I drank
on because you can see it in your sleep
pattern.
That's amazing.
I go from one to get one of these
sessions and then the other thing it
tells you I can even tell when I smoked
a lot of weed that day.
What was the difference?
Really?
If I smoked too much weed and my wife
will tell you,
you know you were snoring.
I went by ambulance at one and smoke 50
fucking join.
That makes you snore more.
Something probably because you relaxed.
Good.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
You're probably out there.
Fucking cold.
Brian Red Band desk squad number six on
the podcasts.
On itunes.
Right now.
Number six bitches.
That's pretty strong around guys.
Oh Shit.
What'd you just congratulate?
Reward as the Lincoln Dude.
That's strong.
That's from the icehouse chronicles.
Alan.
Also Brian Cowen show.
Now is it just going to call it the
Brian counts gunshot,
which I like.
Which I liked too.
He doesn't even know the name.
He was trying to figure out if he should
have a theme,
but I'm like,
he's so interesting.
Why box yourself in that guy can just
ramble on about anything.
You know,
he's,
he's one of my favorite dudes to talk to
and that podcast we had with Dane Cook.
That was amazing.
That was interesting.
And that dude,
Tj Miller apparently wants to talk to me
about it.
I would talk to them about it.
You know,
I,
I don't hate that dude.
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't,
I don't think it's a good idea to go on
long rants about people working out
material that haven't been on stage for
a year though.
I just,
that's just,
that's just how feel,
you know.
Joey,
what are you doing?
Just checking on something which is
called listen,
I,
I don't know what it was about.
I didn't,
I don't give a fuck if you don't know.
It's about everybody should bump Jane
Cook,
bumped them,
dump,
bumped everybody at the laugh factory
which happens on stage and while it does
happen all the time,
you know,
but what I said to Dan really does stand
true.
Like really he doesn't have to do that
and it's a strong move to just come on
after everybody.
It's a strong move to like let everybody
else go on stage and then you go on last
man,
you're the big star.
I agree.
And like tell everybody like let them
know,
hey Dane Cook is going to be on later.
Yay.
So then these guys do their time.
They will get.
Wait,
it ain't that hard man.
It ain't that hard to wait.
But it's a thing that we had to
experience where we're coming up.
Uh,
it was a constant thing.
It always has been that way,
especially in La when a big guy shows
up,
whether it's Jerry Seinfeld or whoever
the fuck it is,
they show up,
they get on stage and part of that
thrill is that the audience members know
that if they come to the Improv,
it's very likely one night that may be
Daniel Tosh or walk on walk on stage.
Even if he's not on the schedule that
may be someone that you've seen on TV.
We'll walk on stage and that's a part of
the thrill.
And in,
in the,
the standup comic does the famous ones
in exchange,
they do these sets for free.
The,
for the,
for their ability to just go onstage
anytime they want.
And it does seem unfair to the people
that are coming up.
I completely agree.
You know,
it's,
it's unfair,
no doubt about it.
I don't do it.
But,
um,
I understand,
I under,
I understand that the idea behind it
because every comic has had to deal with
that.
I the only time I've ever bumped
anybody's when I show up the club and
then they asked me,
would you like to go on stage?
I'm like,
if it's not a big deal,
I'll go on stage,
but I don't want to fuck anybody's night
up and then they'd go and check and make
sure everything's okay,
but if there's any drama or bullshit at
all,
I would way rather just go on last.
Just put me on after everything's done.
Like what?
You can't.
You can't perform at the end.
Everybody is so terrified of someone
strong going on before them,
which is so silly because that's what
you want.
You want.
Everybody laughed.
The reason why I started bringing you on
the road with me,
the reason why I bring an Rv on the road
with me or done because they're fucking
hilarious.
I went to the Improv twice in the last
10 days and both times people came up to
it.
They had to leave and go do it.
Yeah.
They don't want to go on after you know
I don't give a fuck because I'm going to
get off stage and you're still going to
be in the bar drinking.
Take that bottom,
break it over your fucking head so
before you come lie to me that you have
a showcase at the store or you gotta go.
Just be mad.
There was a show that just show then,
but don't come up to me and say you got
to go up because your agency and your
agents at all meat and cheese doodles
don't.
Don't tell that she was a lot of that at
the store.
Guy would claim that he had a showcase.
There was guys who used to get sets.
They couldn't get sets,
but they could get sets when they had
showcases so they would lie and say they
were having a showcase and nobody was
showing no.
I got a call and say I'm accommodating.
And was my youngest moved?
Yeah,
that was my young love.
That movie letting Mitzi ice to melt.
That's what he did.
He started having regular showcase.
They give you a nine slash 15 spots to
come in and say hello,
get a drink.
Some bitches,
you know,
that's,
that's where you see the fake it till
you make it mentality,
you know,
when you're in the,
the,
the dirty stages of standup development,
you know,
when everybody's scrounging for morsels
are all trying to get onstage as much.
Especially like,
I don't know how the fuck anybody starts
in La.
That's brutal.
Brutal.
I mean,
I already did it already.
Basically did his whole career here.
But uh,
you know,
he,
he got,
yeah,
he and he got in early at the store too.
He got stage time.
He got plenty of stage time.
That's huge man because he got in like
just a couple of years and it was career
when we started hanging out with us,
you know,
like we started taking them on the road.
He was,
you know,
just a few years into his career.
You know,
it's amazing how,
how last year I put it together.
I didn't know to about 18 to two years
ago how much I missed the store.
Not The fucking dickheads,
but how much I missed that type of
performing every night and that's why I
made a note now that I always try to go
to crazy places at least every 10 days,
twice a once a week.
I got to go someplace where it's
unpredictable.
I don't want to be in a comedy store
setting because I want that comedy
store.
The what made me a comic was going up at
1145 after you have to fucking tyree
after Mooney by the matter of fact,
I do ms Dot Paula.
Morning.
I missed that.
You want me to tell you?
Uh,
I missed the expression that everybody
gets,
that Nigga wake up call.
I really do because it helps me.
It hit home with me so much more.
When we went to Miami,
they kept saying Cuba come in.
Those Cubans,
this,
we got that Nigga wake up call with the
little kid that they came with the idea
that when they had that pulled them out
of the closet,
whatever.
Fidel came right in that governor said,
go take them.
She met me.
She said,
go down there and take them.
They weren't right until the name.
What the fuck was that all about?
What was that all about?
Aliens.
Gonzalez Gonzalez.
What was,
what was that?
And now he's a patriarch in Cuba.
He's crazy.
Dick up like fucking really?
That joker.
Who's the retarded kid that had this TV
show?
Corky corky.
He's like that with a bib on and Cuba in
1950 cadillac with raft kid.
He's good looking now.
They just had a thing.
His mother died and he was fucking
floating out there on a twig and some
fishermen pick them up.
Imagine what is going to happen when
Fidel died because there was a fake.
Fidel died a thing on twitter the other
day.
People are wondering,
what about the time I told Eddie Fidel
died and he was with Dana White and he
thought it was a bad conversations with
the died.
Did you ever hear about that?
So I'm going to Cuban place and he calls
me [inaudible].
What's up?
I got nothing.
I'm overheating cubic foot.
And you know Eddie likes all that
revolutionary down.
I go to Gio.
There's a rumor going around brother
Fidel Catholic.
I said,
Fidel died.
She's like,
well,
let me go online.
So he goes online.
He was.
Hold on Dana White's right here.
Let me ask him.
Date is online looking for chocolate.
Don't die.
Wouldn't you want to verify that?
Hold on.
Did you just say
Ladelle?
Chuck Liddell when you want to verify
that.
I call bell and see filled.
I said look down.
Was he on the rampage?
Was He a.
was he a Tomahawk in?
No,
no,
no.
He was a Tomahawk and no,
no,
he was straight.
It was like 8:00
once I'd Indian comes out.
Right.
I remember when you first started saying
that about him.
Oh my God.
Because people don't know what that is.
It's something that's in your jeans when
you're digging up that when you drink,
you go to the other fucking direction.
When I drink,
I wish,
but I don't say shit.
I got to go home.
Some people drank a fucking fight.
I mean bro,
you,
you grew up in Boston.
You really seen motherfuckers that would
have two beers and take their shirt off
in 10 degree weather and want to fight a
black bar.
Like we're going down that block and
you're like,
you're not fucking,
are you fucking kidding me guy?
You cannot do that.
But there's people that drink and don't
say nothing.
There's people that drink and giggle.
That's just some people that some people
are not supposed to be.
I hope they recognize it.
The most important thing is that they
recognize it because they think it's fun
until they see it,
you know,
it's fun to them.
Like they just disappeared.
Like how fun would it be if you stopped
being Joe Rogan and went into his face
for eight hours and then woke up with
fucking scars on your fucking pubic hair
on your face and a handcuff on.
It is amazing to me though when people
have such different reactions to certain
drugs,
you know,
and that alcohol is really one of them.
That's.
So it's like until I met Eddie,
I didn't believe in blackouts.
I didn't believe it didn't believe.
People tell me they blacked out,
like how convenient chips always tell
you that they suck your dick in your ass
all the next morning I blacked out.
What happened?
You know what happened?
My fucking ass.
Like a savage.
Hold on.
What happened?
I don't remember any.
Oh my God,
we did that.
Came on your fucking neck.
Remember?
What?
Did you speak in a rape man?
I saw that movie.
The girl with the Dragon Tattoo.
Holy Shit.
That's a bad ass bitch.
Ooh,
that girl who plays it.
I've never seen her before.
I don't know who she is,
but that girl can fucking act.
That's a crazy movie,
man.
Whew.
There's some scenes in that movie.
It felt like a movie where they were
trying to.
It was in fact a book that they were
trying to condense down into movie form.
It was really hard because it's
obviously very,
very good located in involved,
but as you know,
it doesn't fail as a movie.
It's fucking good.
There's some,
some bad ass scenes,
but that check is wild.
Gina Carano movie.
No review.
I heard the reviews are spectacular.
They said that rotten tomatoes gave it a
100 percent,
which is like nobody ever sees that.
I mean that it's temporary because the
cuts will come out and find out about
it.
He didn't clear right online and some
asshole comes on as their shit all over
it just because he knows it and went to
the movies and said that the trailer
Gina Day,
they asked me that.
It looks wild.
They go,
it's fucking great.
It looks great as it come out this
weekend that I know it did good.
I want one guy wide.
The one I seen,
I heard it's bad ass.
Bad Ass.
I heard like the God,
that guy's like a real artist who
created it,
you know,
he,
he really knows what the fuck he's doing
and he really created this around her.
You know of the world needs more ass
kicking checks.
Fun.
We'll get the one chick that trying to
make it.
She's a bad motherfucker.
The Australian check with Kate
Beckinsale oh,
bad ass bitch.
That bitch is bad.
I've seen up close and personal.
Toronto is so legit though.
Come around the world and you know what
she's like,
really like now that Cyborg tested
positive.
It shows it shines a light on all the
cyborgs,
past victories,
and you gotta you gotTa.
Look at it and go,
man,
it's unfortunately cast doubt tasks down
in her old career,
especially since they released a video
that showed her first fight ever in her
first fight ever.
She was not built like that at all.
Not even remotely.
You know,
she changed and she changed pretty
radically and it doesn't seem to be
endogenous chemicals.
If you have an initial video of her from
a long time ago,
they chose a different body,
different body types,
and that's not,
you know,
you're not a man.
Well,
how are you?
How are you doing that man?
So you've got to look at that man and
say,
this Gina Carano man,
if she didn't know that would have been
imagined.
Gina Carano versus route Ronda Rousey
two of the hottest chicks to ever fight.
Ever going at it.
Do you know nuts that fucking fight?
Would it be to stone cold?
It's gonna Hands.
That's the next one to tens that are
killers and they're throwing down Gina
Carano versus Ronda Rousey would get
like,
that's like a fight that actually could
make it into the UFC.
Like that's a fight.
We're Dana white would be like,
you know what,
alright,
this fight.
I would have this fight in the UFC is
like a special attraction.
I mean I'm just guessing it would do
that.
He would probably have like a big event
for strikeforce,
but I mean,
could you imagine the kind of press you
can get when you get to chicks who are
super hot,
who actually can fucking fight both of
them?
She'll get the winter of those two
because it made sense to me today at the
movie did really well.
If she would have fought in June or July
and she wouldn't have done well then the
movie,
they said,
fuck it.
Stay away from everything.
Just let the movie come out,
pop it.
All of a sudden the fucking Brazilian
comes up positive and she's back in the
fucking game.
The movie big.
Great.
She's back in the fucking game now,
so she's going to probably get the
winter of tea,
take on a fight,
man.
See what,
why would she,
why would she want to fight if this
movie?
Then she just goes off and you know,
man,
brain damages for keeps.
If you don't want to fight,
you shouldn't be fighting.
You know,
fighting is something you should only do
when you absolutely want to do.
Just that.
If she,
if she really has this call on the back
of her head,
she wants to get back in there and test
herself.
You know,
she's,
she's a bad ass chick.
She wants to do that.
But I love it.
A debt.
No,
no reason to do it.
If she doesn't,
she's got an amazing opportunity.
She has an opportunity that very few
humans ever get to be a real legit
female movie action star.
I mean,
she's,
she's going to say the right things.
She's smart.
She's not a mean person.
She's a humble person.
She's like,
she's like a happy,
friendly person that people like root
for,
you know,
even checks like her,
you know?
And then also they like about her.
She's not like real skinny.
She's not all skinny and bones.
She's,
she's got meat on her.
oh it's high fat.
That man.
Yeah,
I liked that.
I don't like,
I don't like skinny on a girl.
It doesn't.
I like a girl is not afraid to eat,
you know,
to me,
don't go and get sloppy.
Let's not get crazy.
But you can get a little fat,
little fat.
It's actually kind of sexy.
Something dirty about it.
Keeps the monkey fresh.
Does it?
And lubes the joints,
the joints.
It was some fucking ice and I acetone
and Khloe line and shit.
Everything's good.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
The world needs more bad ass superhero
chicks.
This dragon tattoo check.
And this is Gina Carano check.
I seen that other fucking crazy ass
movie.
Black Swan with mine.
Occula.
Whatever her name is.
That bitch.
Get the fuck out of the professionals.
Little girlfriend cause she's the one in
it as the black swamp.
I don't tell me I'm going to watch the
beginning.
It scared me out.
But the ending of this movie is very
fucking.
I seen the last hour last night and it
really helped me.
It was shit on television.
I wanted to watch them like,
wait a second.
The one girl is all grown up.
I can't believe that was her and the
professional.
That movie's a fucking great movie.
It's a great machine.
It was on the I nine.
I watched Gary Oldham is fucking great.
He would pop the pills and throw his
neck back and heroin and shooting
motherfuckers and carry.
Homo was great in that movie.
He was great.
Danny Aiello is even in that movie.
Oh yeah.
He's the,
he's the hit,
but he's the guy that gives uh,
the Italian guy.
The assignments and shit.
Yes.
Fucking Danny Aiello.
I think he even stopped doing comedy
now.
Denny a lot.
He had a comedy club in hoboken on
Tuesday night place and he would put my
name up on a bunch of comments.
The songs?
Yeah.
Are you serious?
I swear to God.
What was that show that he had on CBS
for awhile?
A Terra Nova something.
Look it up.
The last disaster of CBS,
a melon Ghana or something like that,
that he was a PA public investigator
Chrysler on 10 TV,
whether it's people's name.
How do you suppose named Danielle?
I know a I e l l o
pressure on CBS News in Columbus,
Ohio and he got to do the weather and it
was so fucking hilarious.
If you what?
What did he do?
He was just like acting out like if it
was cold,
but for her,
you know,
and like just making a.
He was just burnt Chrysler on the
whether it was.
What if you could imagine.
That's awesome.
Is that TV show than Gosha Della
Delavan?
Look at the IMB be.
I'm looking at it.
Nineteen 98.
That was the last temptation of Christ.
What year was this?
[inaudible] 98,
which will delve into Aventura when we
first started hanging out in Miami.
When they put his picture up at the
Improv,
I clipped it onto my shirt and yeah,
I kept it out.
He was my favorite,
a goof for awhile.
I have all those on the.
I still have those old vhs sussman.
When they were,
they had the king of Queens over at CBS.
I got them to get me the tapes from the
Delavan tour show because it was so
delicious now and have people come over
and watch it with me.
We wouldn't get high and watch it like
it was a comedy,
so fuck.
It was a great show.
He would always win no matter what
happened.
This is what I remember.
He had a meeting with this guy about
some information that could lead to the
conclusion of my case.
Susan there playing pool and he can't
mess just fucking rocketing balls in and
the guy goes,
worst acting of all time.
The WHO's playing goes,
hey man,
you're the best I ever seen.
What's your secret?
He goes,
my secret,
don't miss.
And it was like fights.
He would get in fights and he's a rusty
old man.
I mean he's old,
he's old,
he's old.
I mean,
we're not talking about US investors to
loan old worries,
you know,
shooting fucking synthetic hormones into
his body every day and he's 64 years
old.
That's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking like he looks like an old
man,
but meanwhile he's knocking dudes out
with one punch.
Pop like,
guys,
give them trouble.
Hey,
get outta here.
He just everywhere he goes,
like no one's hitting him.
He's never got a struggle.
Yeah,
he's dominated everything.
He's just the coolest cop of all time
and it's so ridiculous that it becomes
funny.
It's becomes really subtle.
So Nice.
We're going to sit alone and crazy
Italians,
I guess frank stallone's been coming
back to the boxing gym.
Justin's and they can't take them no
more.
So the quickest way to get rid of
Frankston loans to put wrap on.
Oh really hates rap music.
So they put rap on like,
you know,
Nwa and they have bets on how long the
loan or last and really.
So he's in their shadow box and he'll
look at the speakers,
he'll fuck it.
Then he'll come up to them and say,
listen,
why don't we listen to some good music
put on one of my albums?
And they all look at him like,
are you fucking serious?
He'll give you his album.
You know that frank stallone and gives
album albums.
He plays right here at fucking Malibu.
The Malibu when?
Once a month he's got the.
You got to go as a goof on time.
All the Italian show update.
Kiss him.
What do you think his relationship is
like with his brother?
What do you think it would be?
It must be crazy.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Locked the door behind you.
Dumb fuck.
I'm going to invest in a cheeseburger
chain and you're going to be the head
singer.
That guy's got to come in every day with
a different pitch.
Slide.
Don't mean to bother you,
but listen,
we've got an idea for a new movie.
I think they even made a movie together.
The one with dice that die sued
everybody.
Remember?
They all just alone.
Remember that for no.
A movie about golf?
Yeah.
Lilly,
about when we were at the store were
telling us a story that night and didn't
never got.
Never got released because it is fucking
horrible.
It is frank stallone,
directing and shit.
It's the loans.
Got All his friends and it's still bad
pictures of birds and fucking people
drinking water loans,
hitting a golf ball and shit.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Frank fucking stallone.
Oh my God.
That is hilarious.
That'd
be a weird thing to have a brother
that's like super duper famous and
you're just hanging on trying to make
some shit happen.
That's gotTa to be frustrating as fuck.
Probably makes you want to be famous.
Also like look at Charlie Murphy,
you know,
and he's probably,
that's why he.
Well it is totally with Charlie,
but Charlie is actually,
you know,
he's made it.
He's making money,
he's doing well,
he's in movies,
doing great with standup and then
there's like,
you know,
the Baldwin brothers where everybody
makes it,
you know,
everyone sort of sort of,
kind of that they made it for a little
while.
All of them were in the light for awhile
while,
but now it's only Alec.
He's the only one who,
he's the most talented though,
right?
Yeah.
Oh definitely.
That's what it is.
Like talent just rises to the top.
Like there was another one I liked,
but I only bought one billy William.
Now William,
I think will's a difference.
Bill.
He's the handsome one.
Williams the one with the big face I
think I'll see.
I don't remember.
But he's handsome too.
He's just handsome.
Like,
like he drank a lot of sodium filled
products.
Sodium.
Yeah,
they are A.
I mean there's a bunch of families where
there's a bunch of different brothers or
get in and everybody does so.
So,
but one guy is like the best.
But the ball.
Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
Well that's the most ridiculous
whenever.
Right?
Right.
You know,
you imagine growing up with someone
who's uh,
your brother and you,
you're both doing the same thing and you
just can't fucking hit.
And this guy's just gotTa.
That's gotta be nuts,
man.
Sibling rivalry is a motherfucker.
Look at Mcdonald's brothers.
She threw that motherfucker out.
What happened?
Like she threw him the fight and that
guy was just creepy.
He was opening up shit with her name.
I mean it just gets old Mcdonald's
brothers and stiff.
He's got a brother that wrote the book,
the tell all book.
Now he just had something on the AOL
Google the other day that he's homeless
and Michigan is just the won't help them
because you get fucking creepy on these
people.
Don't,
can't get previously a family.
You can't.
Right.
Tell all books and the same thing that
makes them.
Madonna could also make a loser.
You don't.
You don't get a Madonna with
conventional child rearing and paying
off the right amount of attention to
your kids.
Know you get a Madonna.
If you fucked up,
you get a madonna.
If you ignored that kid,
If somebody did something to it,
an early age that made her determined or
you get a guy,
a guy,
one of the same thing.
You don't get those.
Those chicks are in the.
It's not easy to develop one of those.
You've got to give him some pain.
You got to do so things.
Did you rather fuck Madonna or Gaga?
Right now I'm going Gaga for sure.
Yeah,
she's hot.
Her body is hot as fuck.
Dude.
That fucking pretty bad ass.
Not really.
No.
Diamond got old macdonald last week.
She got old.
She's trying to force those biceps and
tell people she's a Jew and I did have a
dream that I ran into Madonna and all of
a sudden she was young again.
It's amazing.
You just brought this up because I had
this dream last night and I'm just
remembering it now.
It was one of those really fucking Nutty
Alpha brain dreams,
which no one will deny if you.
You could say you don't think that Alpha
brain works.
It doesn't seem to affect you and
enhance your cognitive function.
That's all.
Well and good.
You know,
I don't know how your brain works,
but you can't tell me that it's not
super reliable for making crazy dreams
because I don't know if I can take a
pill that I knew for sure if I took the
shit before bedtime.
Apparently it's not working for
everybody though.
A lot of people say they're not getting
the lucid dreams.
You know,
a lot of times at the beginning of it.
You headed at the beginning,
but then I stopped having them real.
Yeah.
Well,
I get them intermittently and I never
know when they're coming,
but I got one last night and it was
super vivid and last night it was me
hanging out with Madonna and I was being
like real creepy with her.
I was like,
it was weird because she was like,
actually it was like some sort of a
weird thing like I was,
I was much younger than I am now.
Um,
I remember because I remember I had no
family and no responsibility in my dream
is that I just asked me how I know about
them in a bar,
like a shitty bar.
Nope.
It was some weird fucking a booth of a
club and I'm like really close to her
skin and I'm admiring her skin and I'm
telling her,
wow,
you look amazing.
Like I'm really like blown away.
It was like,
because I guess I had,
I couldn't figure out in the stream
whether I'd traveled through time or,
you know,
whether uh,
I lived in a different place when it
was.
I actually 17 years old and when she
actually 24 it was I was in 1984,
1985 again,
or was this supposed to be?
She rejuvenated and she's now 20 years
old again and now she looks hot as fuck
because she looked even younger than she
looked.
When she became famous there was a
really weird dream because I couldn't
figure out what was happening in it.
I couldn't figure out if,
you know,
I was like,
why?
Why do I feel like I'm a young man?
I could just,
but I also have all this information in
my head.
It's very strange,
but I met Don to.
I used to have a thing for Madonna man
when I was young.
I thought she was hot as fuck because
she was dirty.
She was dirty,
dirty Italian.
When you're young,
a young little 17 year old savage with
your hormones on full blast like I was.
I was like so excited that a girl is
dirty.
She's dirty.
That pitch.
Yeah.
What?
She's like the original snookie.
How dare you fucking.
I used to go to this club called making
yourself laugh when I was in high
school.
I was a senior in high school.
I used to go to this club called,
I can't remember it now,
and when I was in there every Saturday,
you know was a girl would come in.
I don't even know who the fuck the girl
was and they let us say,
but I've never really paid attention
because he was lip singing,
just play a song and that's terrible
data really.
She was saying back then back then,
well
it was a club.
It was at this goal,
a rooftop or something and a Dj and
Austin.
They go,
we have a special for somebody to come
in.
She's going to sing a song,
and it was madonna singing.
I'm like,
Lucky Star.
We didn't.
Yeah,
we didn't know at that time it when they
first started having videos on MTV and
you for folks today that live in this
day and era,
this is not going to be impressive,
but back then when Madonna first started
having these music videos like burning
up,
that's a.
that's all she took.
She took with Donna Summers,
was doing it and was like,
you know what,
you just not being clear enough what you
want.
Let me tell you what I'm looking for.
I'm looking to where it crosses and get
fucked hard.
I'm going,
we're going to wear lace and get choked
that you want to be,
but you can't let go.
Come on,
let's go.
I'm burning.
I'm burning in sex.
Tremendous,
tremendous.
Then she had that dancer body with a
little plumpness to her too.
You know,
like she was eating well for the first
time in her life.
God Damn desperately seeking.
Susan came on the street.
She does a million fucking people.
Yeah.
People don't even know what a gay.
Nobody was like a female.
Michael Jackson at that point.
Michael Jackson had been there with her
and 84 and a half close Manhattan.
Yeah.
People I don't are really even aware of
how big Madonna at one point in time,
you know Janet blue?
Yeah.
The second one is like a virgin,
which is good.
That's a great one to blue.
Isn't that fucking good?
But it's got a couple.
It's got a uh,
you abandon me.
Love the old jam,
Bro.
Do you know what I put on twitter that I
thought of you the best fucking jam of
all time?
The Best Leonard Skin it.
Fuck led Zepplin Fuck Pink Floyd because
there is nothing better than groove is
in the heart dog.
The other morning I heard on the radio,
I almost pulled over.
Check the dancing girl.
She got arrested for heroin.
Really?
Tonight when nobody's around and nobody
smoke,
a half of dubin put the video on and
watch it.
Watch it.
That Chinese kid was doing and awesome.
Bootsy collins.
That was awful.
Fucking jail.
I don't care how bad of a mood.
Urine and you can be in a bad mood doing
something.
And by the middle of that second verse
to the entity that you just started
fucking not dancing,
but you're like,
you know what?
It could be worse.
Look at this.
She loved the way that girls.
What's he saying?
That began says so let's play it.
Can we play it?
Yeah,
they're not.
They're on jail.
Just fucking fine.
Meanwhile,
it's owned by.
So we heard the gym one time and you
were singing that.
Which grilled buffalo stand.
Oh yeah.
Sherry and Sherry fucking name Jam Nina.
She had a couple of good ones.
What was the with the buffalo state.
I love Nina Cherry.
She hot as fuck.
No need a chair is way hotter.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened man.
Sherry,
she had.
She.
She had so much potential to.
When you saw her singing,
you like that girl's star.
And then Tracy Chapman.
Tracy Chapman.
But before Tracy Tracy Chapman had a
bunch of big heads,
the thicker black chick over over a
oval.
Amaa trading Joan.
Joan arbitrating shit.
Fuck.
What was that one?
Come on now.
Don't make me get into John Arbitrator
in this motherfucker.
What is was that one scared me.
She was like,
that bitch got sick.
What was that one hit that she had?
Man,
this is driving me nuts.
The slow one bro.
She had somebody.
Brian,
shut the fuck up.
Okay.
You don't remember?
I don't remember her name.
She had one fucking killer song,
man.
And I know this song now Dan.
This is something like that.
The slow jam.
That was fucking amazing.
She had.
Yeah.
Dammit.
I'm going to have to buy her whole
fucking thing on itunes.
On Youtube.
Just pressing of Joan arbitrating and
they'll come up with the songs that were
popular because I ain't got the same
fucking problem sometime.
Okay.
We go.
So when was your episode of General
Hospital on?
Because you were on it today.
Today.
Luke and law.
Tracy and Anthony.
Oh Man.
I wish I would've known.
I've been like watching nonstop general
hospital and I've been looking for it.
I did not see.
How many are you doing?
I did four.
They focused on my boss.
Can I?
Can you.
Can you watch it online?
Did they have like General Hospital in
line on it?
You can watch it online or something.
I think it's on Hulu.
I heard that they were trying to.
We're trying to move tonight.
My Tele novellas.
Yeah.
Oh Dude,
please,
please play this.
Come on please play Joe and Ahmed
trading.
Call me names.
What I'm talking about.
That's the song nobody remembers Jonah.
Jonah betrayed.
Oh she this.
This is the jam,
man.
I forgot about this song.
A bad ass man.
She was one of the original fan.
Yeah,
I'd say the children's hospital.
You to play this,
Brian.
I don't care if we get to play this.
Just play on your laptop.
Can I do that?
So illegal.
But that now that'll have to pause the
youtube.
So when.
When is your trip,
because you're also on children's
health.
Did general grandchildren tomorrow night
for children's hospital and I know when
it was that fun to Hasa.
Yeah,
but I tell you I love that show.
Henry Winkler,
kicking it,
kicking it where I played the meatball
king.
It was like one of Batman's villains.
Oh really?
I have a bazooka.
Like scarface that shoots meatballs
balls.
The kids and shit at the end.
Wait till this comes out.
It's a kid show on Disney.
Alright,
cool.
Kicking it.
I'll kick it with kitchen.
This.
How many episodes do you do to this
general hospital?
For so far I think they're gonna because
Sundays going so any new moms would come
in and smack them.
Bitches know what I'm saying?
What do you have to do?
So far?
I just was a reverend.
I went to jail.
I went to prison and reverend.
Yeah,
I'm married.
I'm a reverend in this.
My name is game runner instead of mad
flavor.
It's game runner game here,
a game runner game running.
Brian,
did you lower my volume now?
Turn it back up and turn that into a
game runner.
Game runner came on the show as a guy
that went to prison with Anthony.
When I went to jail I got my life and I
became a minister,
so I come and married one of his checks
that he kidnapped me straight up.
Kidnaps this chicken.
I married him on the show.
Do you have any scenes with any hot
checks?
AIPAC,
the blonde,
but I didn't know.
Like I watched the first time they got
black people on General Hospital.
I didn't know that.
So talking to you?
Yeah,
it was very shocking to me.
I didn't even see if they passed that
law in 99 and then the brothers fucking
soap operas.
Where is the brothers?
And then she'll have like a black soul.
Well,
son did used to do soap operas,
which was in,
what was he in?
Was he in general hospital or something
like that,
but whatever it was,
he was on top.
Yeah,
we're sons.
Talented man.
That who?
Raja.
For people who don't know,
that's a.
that's a hilarious comedian.
All that.
There's like all these videos of me
arguing with a crazy Brazilian jujitsu
guy online.
That's my friend Russ on and he's A.
He's an Eddie Bravo Brown belts.
He's just an actor.
He's just,
he's this character that he does and
every now and then he'll want to
confront me about some things and get
into this big long arguments like
Eddie's Eddie thinks it's hilarious.
He loves doing it.
So Eddie sets it up all the time,
but his actual name is for song and he's
hilarious.
How funny is it?
That resigned?
Father was my first karate teacher when
I came from.
It's amazing.
So how's that circle fucking flow with
amazing resigns and it was such a great
guy bro.
And we have to get reassigned.
To tell you the story about his father's
karate school,
his father's karate schools on 100
street and Amsterdam.
It was,
it was black.
It was painted black.
The walls were black biggies with black.
Black was beautiful.
It was like 70.
You've got a fist go Jew,
you gotTa fucking fist and said go Jew.
And you've got this thing on the back
and a Japanese letters.
Let me tell you what he used to make us
do.
Her son's father,
he'd make us run to central park
barefoot with the fucking karate
uniforms on.
Know how scared I used to be at barefoot
on the street run,
run,
run.
He makes us fucking run whenever.
Fees on what if you saw broken down?
She'll play.
Didn't give a flop.
That's what toughen you up.
Mine number one.
Time is resigned.
Father kicked me in the stomach when I
was about six.
You know when the ad comes out of you
for the first time I took one,
like I'm wanting to go back to karate,
but he was a good guy bro.
He taught me a lot of good shit.
My first karate,
Joe Esposito,
who's now the head of the,
he's one of the big guys at the
Massachusetts State Athletic Commission,
so they regulate mixed martial arts.
I took her class from him and he signed,
kicked me in the stomach.
They would do bad.
They would say tighten up.
I mean,
he didn't hit me hard.
I was only like 14.
He just gave me a little little tap,
but that was common,
you know,
the instructor would walk by,
tighten up and they'd fucking blast in
the stomach while you're in line,
you know,
you had to always be prepared,
always be solid.
You know,
where the Koreans came over to teach tae
kwon normally walk around with a stick.
Oh yeah.
In the back of the legs if you get.
Koreans were like super strict fluid
restriction.
But because of that there their team was
fucking monstrous.
Man.
The Korean national team for a while
until the,
the real uh,
the Americans got real good at it.
And then there was some other entries
from other parts of the world that were
like really high level.
But for awhile the Koreans just
dominated taekwondo tournament and a lot
of it was the high level training and
the discipline that they had there,
they took it serious.
Now you can't hit your kids no more.
You can't try out a friend.
My friend was,
uh,
going to med school,
my friend junk sick and he,
he won the national championships.
He had it.
He took time off to,
to win the nationals.
He took time off to train,
took time off,
away from the school,
which was a big fucking deal because he
was going through like some serious,
serious fucking schoolwork.
And I remember watching this kid,
I couldn't believe how fucking hard he
worked,
you know,
it was just,
it was incredible to watch.
It was,
it was really like inspiring because
this guy was always tired.
He was exhausted and yet he would still
find time to train and we were talking
about it,
you know,
back then he was a little bit ahead of
me.
He was like,
um,
when I was hitting a national level of
my skills,
he was already there.
So he was like a little bit ahead of me
and uh,
I remember talking to him,
I'm like,
how are you doing this?
Like,
this is incredible that you find time to
do all this school work and yet you
still find time to train.
And he's like,
I barely can do it.
I barely could do it.
He goes,
I'm so tired.
He would like when he was training for
the nationals,
he would do his homework and then he
would put his backpack on with all of
his books and he would run up and down
the stairs in his,
uh,
in his dormitory where he stayed and it
was just,
that's how he would get like a lot of
his cardio training in it would just put
his books in his bag and run up and down
the stairs.
And he would tell me about like how
exhausted he was when he,
when he would come to work out and
train.
But that fucking guy just kept chipping
away.
And it's like,
I learned a lot watching that dude.
Like,
we'll learn that there's like levels of
commitment and discipline and for
whatever reason,
a lot of Asian people instill that in
their children that like real intense
discipline,
you know,
proud of their kid when their kid
becomes a doctor,
proud of their kid when the kid said
something really,
really difficult,
that's a,
that's a mother fucker,
man,
that's a,
that's a to,
to,
to have like that,
that high expectations of yourself,
you know,
you're really setting up for a very
stressful,
stressful life.
And I know he eventually stopped
competing because it was too much,
you know,
to do that.
And he assumed his,
his practice,
you know,
to,
to become a doctor and you know,
and,
and studies to become a doctor.
And he got right back into that now,
but became 100 percent of his focus.
But he did what he wanted to do,
you know,
he got there,
he got where he wanted to get and then,
you know,
he realized his dream and that was just
back to work.
And I was like,
man,
that's a,
that's a tough life.
That's a lot of work.
You don't look at the discipline,
even with the Japanese,
with the Yakuza,
they fuck up.
They gotta cut a finger off.
Yeah.
That's that discipline in the United
States.
Comfortable at work late.
You're going to cut a fucking finger up
and you have to cut it off yourself.
That's the motherfucker didn't see.
If somebody grabs you and cut your
finger up you.
Well you have to go in there with a
knife,
put your hand in thing and tie advantage
over your hand and drive yourself to the
fucking hospital.
I said,
oh,
that's a level of commitment and that's
the fucking up for slipping.
They let you live,
but you fucking finger you.
She was the whole thing or a joint.
Is it like a big thing?
The whole thing off the joint.
Everything really.
They start like they take joints off
though.
They chop like I dunno,
I,
I think that's what it is.
It's digital.
It's like,
what does it matter?
I fuck up and I cut my fucking manicure.
I told my fucking jam or something,
but for me to cut a finger off.
I mean that's just,
that's.
And you do it with honor?
Yeah.
You do it with like you come in and go,
I'm sorry I fucked up out of my respect
for you.
I'm going to chop my fucking finger up
to my family.
That's that.
I was talking to a friend of mine who
had something going on where he was
involved with a bunch of a businessman
and they.
One of them was this Japanese guy that
kept showing off the fact that his
finger was missing like cat.
He would flaunt it.
The fact is in laugh about it,
it's fingers,
Mr.
see that you see that like apparently
like I guess in Japan and must carry a
lot of weight.
Someone sees someone sees you with a
finger that you probably chopped off
yourself like Ooh,
this guy's willing to take shit to a
different level and they've been touting
themselves up for 200 fucking years.
Like the bodysuit body body tax and the
way they do this super painful super
fucking pain.
All that shit is just.
It's a different approach than the
traditional method of tapping that tat
tat tat tat the way they do it very
different than like a needle,
like a,
a tattoo and modern tattoo needed where
they essentially just draw it.
It wasn't like that back then.
That's how Steve got his tattoo and he
will just tie tattoos.
You went to the same person.
That engine Lena Jelly did it and got
the exact same tattoo.
She well for awhile.
Every tattoo that she got,
he would get to.
He would recreate her tattoos.
So fun.
It's taking it to the next level and
really loves her because these crazy I
love.
I love the fact that people like Steve
Will there that I love.
The fact is people that are willing to
climb up a tree and little lion come get
you.
He was great.
We got to get him on this podcast for
sure.
Gets he gets he loathes Angelina Jolie
or.
Yeah.
Well I don't know.
My thing is we love the loves,
the idea of the goof of it.
You know that he's going to get every
tattoo that she gets.
So he went to billy Bob on his arm.
Does he have Billy Bama?
His arm?
No,
but that would be funny.
I don't know if he.
Maybe he took it off when she took hers
off because she took hers off.
He actually took off his shirt on when
we had him on one,
that old podcast at my apartment.
He took off his shirt and showed us all
his tattoos.
Oh yeah.
He's got a shitload of no one's on his
back or a pretty amazing.
And they has a picture of himself on his
back.
He does like,
it looks like an airbrush.
Like perfect.
That's your choice though.
That's really a questionable choice.
I could see getting Angelina's the
tattoos on your body,
but doing a tattoo of your own face.
So what?
The people that got a tattoo?
A George Lopez.
Oh yeah,
that's a fucking statue.
Yeah.
Live with forever.
Will you do.
Now that he got fucking file off 10 do.
Well he's still going to tour and
probably kill him.
He's never going to be at a long for,
for income if he decides to tour,
you know.
Don't you think that guy was selling out
the Hollywood bowl?
Who's selling all giant places?
I just took a flight last week with
Paul.
Regina on the flight.
Oh yeah.
You've got to get up on that microphone.
Sit right next to me talking about the
store and it's pretty interesting to
talk to.
Paul Rodriguez was there in the early
days,
right?
Wasn't he there and that Chico in the
man days when when fucking homeboy
killed themselves.
What was that guy's name to kill
themselves?
Freddie prinze,
Freddie Prinze,
and the guy who took his place was Danny
Maura,
who's also a comedy store.
Regular.
Took his place.
She chicos plays for a season.
Then you weren't going to replace
fucking Freddy parties.
Friends at that time.
Who is to commit?
That jumped off the building of the
comedy store right next door.
I don't know who they're going to
remember that.
Right?
Well,
I heard the story,
but I don't know who.
The guy was mad that some guy jumped off
the building right next to the comedy
store at that though.
Hide Hotel or whatever it's called.
That was during the,
the the riots or the whatever the fuck
it was.
Now there's an advertisement for mad men
on there where it's just a shadow of
somebody falling down that building and
it's so creepy to look at because that's
the shadow.
That's exactly where that guy killed
himself.
I wonder if they knew that now.
I don't think I do.
You don't think that now?
I don't mean,
isn't it?
Yeah,
and a lot of people at the comedy store,
like I said something to them and
they're like,
oh my God,
you're right.
Holy Shit.
I didn't even think of that.
There was anyone that was thinking that
was the boycott,
right?
They boycotted all the clubs.
You know,
back in the day,
comedy clubs in La didn't pay anything.
Now they pay a little bit,
they pay a tiny bit,
but back then they didn't pay a God damn
thing and so guys were packing the place
and killing them.
Then all the clubs were making money and
the truck clubs or treats you like shit.
So the only,
the only place where clubs get away with
that,
they have that sort of slave owner
mentality like some of them do,
some of them do still to this day.
They think that you're doing some sort
of an honor by performing there.
So how many stores really tighten their
ship lately?
That they got a whole new staff and
there are no one's the same anymore.
That it's completely like a normal club
now.
I think.
Which one?
The comedy story.
The last year
they've just pretty much overhauled the
whole entire thing.
So now it's like a food.
Yeah,
it's got food that people are getting
paid or getting spots.
The only thing that you don't see is you
don't see a lot of new comics going
through there a lot.
It's still kind of like the same like
you know,
like a Saturday night live season.
How could it possibly be improving with
those people at the helm?
Yeah.
Well I mean the.
I think Tommy is the only person that,
that,
that you would know their lives are
problem and that bartender people back
all the buckets still there.
Oh yeah.
All those guys are still there.
That guy's cool as fuck.
There was a,
you know,
you talk about it.
We've talked about it.
It was a.
That was a cool time.
You know,
that was a fun place to hang out.
That's what everybody misses about it.
And you know what?
It's a.
It was never was what the ice houses.
The ice house is way better.
It's a way better vibe.
The fact that we got that podcast room
right next to it,
the fact that everybody's hanging around
there and you don't know who's the GM
though now or.
I think he's the GM.
Yeah,
he's the GM is Adam now from Arizona.
So it's like the dean,
the new Dean is the guy that we're
friends with.
It used to be at the,
uh,
the Improv in.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And the manager will good for him,
man.
Go serve this purpose with that.
Yeah.
It was like that bar you went to for a
year when you lived in that place where
you ate,
that it served its purpose.
You know,
it was there for me and moved on.
And I don't even think about it no more
when I drive by that it's weird foreign
fucking place to me.
I'll even try to drive down there.
I have this download today and I drove
by and it's like I don't even look no
more.
It's strange when I do drive by drive by
felt bad if he didn't stop in like I
keep on finding a new place or something
and you're like,
let me stop.
And then.
So we used to do the Improv on melrose
for New Year's
right back to the store and hang out and
keep on finding new rooms and knucks
like I just found a new nut the other
day and I guess it's polly's office
where he got that third set of stairs
and I'm like,
what the fuck is this place all about?
And that's like,
oh this is where you fuck a girl if you
want to.
Or you could smoke weed and like.
And I'm like,
oh this is awesome.
Hilarious.
At that place has got so many tunnels
and secrets and hiding spots.
Does poly still keep an office there?
I think he might,
but he's never there probably.
I never see what does he see him once in
a while?
I do know he's on the road a lot.
I think he does and he's doing movies.
He just released that movie recently
and,
and I don't know what he's doing.
I saw him the other day.
He had a camera crew there where he's
like doing some kind of thing,
like filming something.
I don't know.
Wow.
But he's barely ever there.
There's people like that.
We'd just go,
where is that guy now?
I watched John Barris again this weekend
and both nights.
And that's the best shit about the
economy store when it's.
He,
he,
I think I got there at like one and we
didn't leave the comedy store.
Don didn't finished until like 4:00
AM.
He got offstage.
That's awesome.
You know,
comedy clubs stays till 4:00
AM.
Yeah.
That club is.
We had some crazy things happen in that
place.
Yeah.
Especially that original roommate let
original world was just.
That's a heavenly body,
you know,
that's a,
that's uh,
that's.
There's more,
there's more energy in that room.
There's more history in that room,
you know,
veteran mostly.
Really any club in the country keeps you
in check that room.
Yeah,
always keeps you in check.
You could be at a weekend place all
weekend,
killing Monday.
You pull up the comedy store,
you think good,
bad to the bone and you get not a
fucking laugh.
There's always drama and crazy shit
happening.
Yeah.
Well there is no one's ever like quiet
in the audience.
It's always fucking chaos.
There was a girl Friday night and she
was definitely a hooker that she was
just sitting there using that.
Patty,
a lot of hookers sit at the patio
because they can like,
oh,
like there's a patio in the front that's
outside where people walk back and
forth,
up and down sunset.
So a lot of the hookers just hang out at
the patio and they look like normal
girls at first.
But then he realized what they're doing.
They're just using the patio.
How do they,
uh,
well,
this girl,
this was the most funniest thing ever.
Like we would walk up and everyone's
staring at this girl at the bar and I'm
like,
what?
What's going on here?
And I'm like,
Holy Shit,
but the back of her,
she had only a thong on like a string
Bikini Thong or whatever,
and then just see through a mini skirt.
Like you could see completely her
butthole.
You could see it was crazy,
like it could not be legal.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
And she,
her body was man.
It was all right.
So I was like,
Holy Shit,
that's awesome.
What's going on in there?
And he goes,
dude,
just relaxed way to see her face.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
So I go there and it was like facial
hair,
acne.
It looked like a Mexican dude and drag
her face was just.
So was it a guy or was.
No,
it was just a very unfortunate monster
that decided to wear like from behind it
looked awesome.
I mean I wonder how much she works,
but we asked if we could take a photo or
something.
One of the comics asked like,
can I take a photo with your.
But you know,
because that's how crazy it was.
And she was like 20 bucks the price for
it.
It's like,
you know,
when you take a picture with Spiderman
over at the Hollywood bowl poster or
Hollywood boulevard,
it's a donation,
right?
This story is that why would a hooker
going into a store and try to get money
when there's so many other hookers that
go there?
Something big for free.
Yeah.
Well,
not just using the via the sunset,
so who does stock or sell their selves
without being on the corner?
You know what I mean?
People walk by a storm like,
oh,
look at that girl.
You know there's a funny just walking
that we're willing to suck Dick.
You just had a fucking pulled back.
The audit choke and fucking find out
that you just need the clouds to part to
see the true color of this guy's about
crazy.
Women went to the store.
They go in there.
I mean that'll happen that the fiber
room that'll happen at the house of
Blues.
That whole area is just nuts.
That very famous,
very vegas.
When a woman comes and she moves to La
and she doesn't really know how the
things that could happen.
Yeah.
The things that can happen to a woman,
I'm a producer,
I want to take you out to lunch.
Next thing you know you're getting
fucked by eight fucking I read whatever
the fuck they do,
rags or whatever.
It's just so weird that chances are when
you're a woman like you don't fucking
know.
You know?
Yeah.
You could get lucky and wind up being
Brooke Burke and being on dancing with
the stars and making millions and
smiling or yeah,
you could suck one day,
end up with a bad fucking guy that tells
you who's next thing that you have a kid
you here.
It's just amazing and the same thing.
You know,
it's amazing fucking crap.
Shoot man.
For a woman,
it's way harder,
especially a woman trying to be a hot
chick like I'm trying to be a
professional hot check.
Try and be an actress or something like
that.
Like so many of them in the volume.
The numbers for every Gig that there is,
the number of pretty girls that are
driving in on buses and Lee especially
now with the economy socking,
how many of them were like,
look,
there's nothing here for me.
I'm just going to give it a chance.
Just getting that bus and flying off to
Hollywood.
Woo.
Amazing.
Ah,
well you and I have been here for so
long now.
We've kind of seen how weird it is to
watch people arrive at facebook from
girls that you're like,
oh my God,
what the fuck happened to you six years
ago?
You were sucking dicks behind the store
and now you're a mom in Florida.
Yeah.
To get like,
hey joey,
I don't know if you're remember me and
you look at the picture on facebook.
You're like,
oh my God,
she's got like a crib and she always
looks so much.
They always look way more beat than live
in the porn star pimp lifestyle.
You are relaxed all the time.
You know,
you see him and they have 17 steps so
far today,
but that day I ran into so many crazy
fucking women and men to men,
men,
women,
everything.
That store was the,
it was a,
it was an attractor and it still is an
attractor of crazy people comes up to
you and says,
can I talk to you for is negative,
you know,
you get funny and you know,
I just wanted to be funny and they won't
give me spots.
What do I have to do to get spotted?
And that's the magic answer.
When they just say that to you,
what are they doing?
Guest spots and try to beat around the
bush.
Well,
you could write jokes,
you could go to a standup class or you
can suck my dick.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you got three options and say,
oh my God,
it's.
You had the one girl you talked about in
the podcast and said,
the less of message,
I would send a letter about how your
broker a broker.
And I didn't mean to break us.
She was always willing to suck my dick.
So what am I going remember with dirty
fingernails when night me going,
this is terrible like this and that
little bathroom.
The cubicle on the second floor.
Remember the one by the phone where you
answer that totally.
How many fucking blow jobs that you get
an ad from women that just said,
if you suck my Dick when you put me on
the belly room,
show with you next week.
Hey,
call me and they'll just suck your dick
for a fucking spot.
Like in the belly room.
Like a fucking Steven Soderbergh.
He's going to fucking show up to the.
And if they only knew about Mike
Young's,
just showcase.
It's just a player.
It's just fucking amazing.
Out Women would fall.
I started going on acting class and you
book something and a girl sees you in
acting class.
Oh my God.
They're all over you outside.
Like what do we need to do?
What do I mean when you start sucking my
dick or show me your pussy or something.
You don't have any fucking victims.
I had that with confused from acting
class.
Why?
Actually when I was 415 pounds,
like in 98,
I had this 21 year old let me come over
and fucking in the ass and I would fuck
him and he asked him feel guilty.
Like,
when is she going to realize I'm a fat,
disgusting slot?
This chicken was like,
right.
Staying on that SUV,
taking the garbage out.
Let me suck your Dick.
You hold.
I'm a fucking Costar.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to hold out for the big fucking
star.
She was sucking Dick.
What is wrong with you?
$1,200
for the fucking day.
Just sucking my Dick like I'm some
stock.
I mean,
she was serious.
She was like,
you have some girl that you were,
you,
you were getting in your acting class.
That was also someone else.
Someone was taking care of her.
I don't know if he could say the guy's
name.
He had a black girl.
Yeah.
We'll say it.
I don't give a fuck.
The Nero Nero had done.
Everyone's got like these black chicks
that he takes right from like south
Florida.
You're going to Florida.
Those black chicks are raw,
like go to Orlando and put those black
chicks are mined from pumping out.
They have no fucking Afro Sheen that had
just goes up like Joe and Ahmed trading.
They got fucking tattoos.
That little heavy.
This girl that Deniro had,
he fixed her up.
He gave a fake tits.
He take away on her tattoos.
He gave her the real hair.
He bought that horse has she had this
shit and he put her up in the fucking
thing with Shaq lift and that's how we
got the toddler.
What made you move?
Like,
you know,
sometimes an acting class.
They're like,
well you want to meet at a coffee shop
to do scenes or they either come to your
house,
are you go to that house?
She said,
you want to come to my house?
I'll live in the Wilshire district.
Okay.
I didn't even know what the wish
district is.
I just started driving.
She also had to pull off and there's a
doorman and what the fuck is this bitch
too?
And after a while,
one day she goes,
my boyfriend's Deniro look at the sleep
apnea machine,
but she was telling me the whole story
that she wouldn't see him and he would
just call her on Friday and go get that
black ass wash pop over for dinner.
And it was all over the shop.
How many of those do you think he has?
She said she knew she wasn't the only
one.
That's beautiful.
And so they just do as a no questions
asked policy,
no questions asked when I come to town
to trim down for a long time that buck
wheat for years because was going to
western that fucking cave that.
I mean that's why he's got to keep doing
these movies.
And he's still in Russia.
Those bad ones done some terrible ones.
Bad ones now.
But I think now he's too old and he
enjoy his original original wife to
either heavy set black jake.
That's Kinda cute.
You're like at least she's got some
pizzazz,
but you know,
he had a couple of freaks that he had
out there.
And why not?
I haven't seen a movie of his.
It was good in a while.
It's unfortunate when you think about it
because he's the greatest actor of all
time,
in my opinion.
One of them,
I shouldn't say the Gary Oldman's a bad
motherfucker too.
There's a lot of guys that are bad about
Russell Crowe's bad motherfucker.
This is a lot of bad motherfuckers,
but you go back to like the raging bull
days or the Cape fear days.
Robert Deniro was a mother fucker.
He was amazing man.
And he was the first guy that really
would like change his body.
He gained a fuck load of weight for
raging bull.
Remember,
he got in super good shape as a boxer
and then he gained a lot of weight to
play Ray Lamontagne,
uh,
in the,
in the later years.
That was a fucking amazing performance
drivers.
Amazing performance.
If you see him in taxi driver,
that one scene where he goes to get
Christopher walken and it's his turn and
the guy smacks,
smacks the guy back because you know
you're going to die.
I'm gonna die anyway because we see good
fellas.
How good was he in goodfellows?
How good was he in Godfather to the
beginning?
Yeah.
That shit.
And he became like,
that could be a young brand.
Brandon.
He really fucking had it down.
He was,
bro.
That's one of my favorite movies of all.
Godfather two is one of the most
beautiful fucking.
The Guy who stole that movie for me is
that fucking Guinea.
Fuck.
A five,
five angels.
The guy that no mind jot in Las Vegas.
I don't mind jot in Miami with Hyman
Roth.
That guy that was fucking crazy,
that would always say shit,
that Pachino he was the one that uh,
duval made them commit suicide member.
He went to see him in jail and at the
end of the Romans they have a party and
then they slip that fucking risks and
that,
that movie is a beautiful movement.
They go to Cuba and he tells them,
Hey,
I've seen something really interesting
today.
I seen the rebel blow up.
And he goes,
well,
there's that tell you.
He was a soldier.
Gets paid to fight.
Rebel does it for free.
I don't like it.
I didn't.
I'm not gonna.
Watch the movie again.
Joe Rogan,
I haven't seen that movie fucking movie
again.
I didn't see that on Dvr and I watched
it about a month ago and I was blown
away.
Never seen it.
It started on,
this is how brilliant it starts out
where the mother goes to the don and
Sicily and says,
you killed my husband and you killed my
son.
Spared him.
He's fucking retarded.
You don't.
You don't like it because so many people
like it.
Is that one of those people are wearing
God or good.
What is it called again?
Godfather father.
Posters in their house and they only
talk about it.
It's like,
dude,
that movie came out like 20 years ago
and you're still talking about what's a
great fucking movie?
I know I get it,
but it just wears on you.
She goes,
he goes,
no,
and he shoots the mother in front of.
I don't remember this,
but you're giving spoilers like a
motherfucker,
bro.
He shoots the mother.
Then he goes to Ellis island.
He's alone.
This world,
he's fucking retarded.
He had,
he had yellow fever when he came from.
I don't remember this,
this neighborhood,
but the whole is when he goes back to
Sicily,
he becomes Vito Corleone.
He's got dog olive oil company.
He goes back to Cici to get the guy who
steals,
who kills his mother,
his father and his brother,
and he goes up to 1000 in the stomach
and he fucking rubs his blood on his
shirt.
That fucking acting.
Think about that scene.
He goes,
we'll talk a little closer.
I can ignore number to get a plan.
He goes,
really,
motherfucker,
this is the thing and this is for you,
and he stabs him.
Then he wipes the knife on his fucking
shirt.
You mother fucker.
You motherfucker killing my family,
bitch.
He went back to the boat,
took care of business.
What's a good one?
I just don't know.
I remember that.
I do remember that part.
The same people that like these movies
always have,
like the ringtone is somebody in the
rack pack also.
You know what?
Like Dean Martin,
is that what it is that with frank
stallone likes to work out to music?
No,
it does.
It does.
He try to put it on a Justin's?
Yes.
What kind of music is he saying?
Album of coverage.
Is it good shark bites?
I need this.
I need for you to sing this song.
I've heard 30 million fucking times.
Yeah.
That's not necessary at all.
No,
he's on Lemon Jello.
I don't need that shit.
Peter.
Who people want me to jail.
That was the biggest scam of all life.
Peter Lemon,
lemon gentleman in the seventies,
just marketing group.
Wanted to try something and they took a
fucking guy.
His name is Peter Lemon Jello.
Good looking blonde.
Guy took his picture and one on every
station and said,
get the greatest hits of Peter Lemon
Jello.
Nobody.
No.
Pick the lemon.
Jello.
Watch what the fuck's be the lemon
Jello,
but those are his greatest hits by the
fucking thing.
He sold like a million copies.
Nobody knew what it was.
An album of just covers him singing
merry Christmas and silent night.
Peter Lemon,
Jello.
He was one album.
Made him in the seventies,
if you will,
on TV marketing.
How much it's changed.
I think there's a media marketing.
How much has changed in the seventies?
Guy would go on TV.
The greatest hits,
they didn't have that much.
Right.
So you went back.
Well,
how about when they tried to sell that
dude who was playing the flute,
the Pan Flute,
master of the pamphlet.
What was his name?
Sam Fear.
Zen Masters.
Get the fuck.
It's amazing that that has any effect on
you at all.
You're sitting at home slack,
jaw and there's a dude playing the flute
and you're like,
fucking pamphlet.
I got to get that.
Oh fuck.
You Know Brittany Spears sells 10
million ounce.
Yeah,
but at least that's like pop music.
Do you kind of get.
There's a lot of dumb teenagers out
there.
Sort of connects with the type of people
that want frivolous dance music,
but I don't get the pamphlet.
There's a bunch of dudes would do like
different master of the right.
Yeah.
And they sell them like in meditation
places also fear.
I bet a lot of dudes are pissed that he
got that master of the pamphlet contract
because you know,
I mean,
how many dudes were playing the pan
flute going one day?
That's going to pan out.
The only guy panned out for was them
fear.
That fear.
That's it.
When you pull the thing,
a trombone
slide,
slide whistle thing that you think in
that Russell probably placed in this
home,
what would you say,
please?
This slide was.
It looks like he would.
I'm sorry.
I'm just bitter with him.
You don't like Russell brand?
He said,
Katie,
is that what it is?
You're upset about that.
Really?
Why are you a fan of Katy Perry?
I Love Katy Perry.
Do.
If you had a chance,
would you be with her?
Of course I would do lover.
I want to marry her.
So you upset at Russell?
I obviously didn't work out.
Yeah it but don't get fucking married.
Russell brand.
He's also supposedly,
he's English.
He's Dick.
Smells like shit.
He's got fucked up teeth and he's trying
to fuck her in the neck.
That goes to 26 year old girl from
fucking up north.
She's a good girl.
Good girl.
And you treated her bad that she's
fucking singer,
man.
She's a famous singer.
How do you know she's not crazy?
Yeah.
It might be just like a female comic.
She just wants to talk about her songs
all day and publicists and maybe she's
nuts.
You don't know.
She comes in and puts that shit.
Don't,
don't play that role.
Brian,
how dare you.
He uses the word telly.
Telly.
I liked when I say proper,
it's a proper love.
Russell restaurant.
He's an animal.
He's a proper funnels.
He's 30 years old.
He's 50,
50,
50 fucking years.
You don't need to look really planners
or did a lot of drugs.
There's a lot of drugs.
He's afraid you can't do nothing.
Nothing bothered me.
I like to get together.
You let what you like to watch.
That piece of shit.
Why don't you watch your original one?
The original one?
The original ones.
Great.
There was no reason that we make that
original is great.
There's no reason to make it,
but they did a pretty good job.
It was a good movie.
See the same exact character that he's
in in every single day.
Pretty much,
but that's okay.
So is a fucking Jason Bateman or not?
It was the name.
What the fuck's his name?
The,
the,
the guy from the,
the uh,
the balding guy from England,
Justin.
Oh God damn the mechanic there.
Jason.
Jason,
Jason say that.
Sorry.
About a month ago to a mechanic isn't.
There's nothing.
I said to myself,
you know what,
how can I put down a movie?
I haven't seen a.
and let me just take the Charles Branch
and notion off.
It might be a good movie,
right?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Just get mad at it.
Oh,
he minutes in because that's the beauty
of the mechanic.
If you watch the original mechanic,
it's the beginning.
It's the longest dragged out scene of
all time and it's one of the best hitch
you'll ever see on film where he breaks
into the guy's house and puts you to
sleep and peace to a pills and the Dang.
And,
and what he does is he puts the gas on a
shooter,
so it looks like a fire.
He did a very.
And that's what I told people at the
mechanic,
wasn't about a guy blowing up things.
It was about a 51 year old man that has
to use his trades and he did everything.
He didn't want it to seem like he was
shooting.
It wasn't a fucking act like,
you know,
if he would look
at your medical records,
if you had a weak heart each shoot at
your legs,
so you would have to run.
That's how he killed Jeremiah.
Michael Vincent's father in that movie.
I watched that thing with Jason Strand,
Bro.
No,
no.
Fifteen minutes.
It went right off.
It was a little too stylized and like
the fight scenes like that.
Vincent was trotting slams much.
Jen might go.
Vincent was a cool mother fucker walking
into the room.
Microphone jobs.
Bronson was a cool motherfucker walking
into the scene and I think that guy that
played jam,
Michael vintage rolls are good fucking.
He's a great actor,
but he overdid the role.
Really?
Yes.
The role wasn't for a kid.
That was crazy.
It was for a kid that was spoiled to
different vinyl.
Maybe they played it crazy in this
movie.
You know when you're spoiled,
when you're spoiled kid and your parents
have a lot of money,
you're spoiled like that.
That's what he was,
you know,
he was a bad ass in 30 days of night.
Who's that guy?
That same guy that played the Jan Marini
is great and he's a good actor.
I don't want them to remake and Charles
Bronson movie.
No,
you know,
no matter what you do,
it's like you don't have to remake the
movie man.
How much?
Just make another movie about a young
man.
Why can't I hit?
Why?
Yeah.
Why can't you make another movie about a
Hitman and just cause you guys rolling
in his grave.
You worked hard to be a scumbag.
And Austin,
this guy comes with his pretty face and
shaved head and all of a sudden he's
fucking shooting people by my fuck you.
Fuck you.
Says what's up Joe Rogan go this week.
Italian beef sandwiches.
It's going to be off the fucking chain.
The only ticket to the left folks are
nosebleeds.
Are you serious?
So I was left.
People know the way back,
I guess is a,
it's a giant place with.
It's like 3000,
200 people or something like that.
It's huge.
People driving from Canada.
I'm going to have some fucking fun.
We're selling.
We made posters to Mike Maxwell.
He's a,
he's a serious fucking real deal.
My Art Dot Com is a bad motherfucker.
And Matt,
Mike Maxwell,
art on twitter,
that's his twitter handle.
And he's uh,
he's coming with us and he's going to
sign some posters too if you want to get
your shit signed and we'll all sign it.
Wall side.
Get one brother ones when these crazy.
We're going to have some fun.
It's a killer.
Pop.
The card is sick man.
There's a lot of good fights of the
bisping Chael Sonnen fighting already
talked about.
Rashad Evans is going to take on Phil
Davis.
That's a good fucking.
I find.
I like that fight a lot.
That's a really interesting fucking
fight.
And Damien Maia is going to take on
Chris Weidman.
That's a good fight,
right?
And they took that fight on short
notice,
but that kid's a stud wrestler.
Who knows how to put people to sleep,
you know,
he put Tom Law to sleep in the fucking
with darce choke killer.
He's a killer.
And you know what?
Matt Serra is a serious Jujitsu coach.
You know,
a lot of people don't remember that Matt
Serra was at one point in time when he
was competing and just straight
grappling was right up there at the top
of the fucking heap.
He wanted decision over John John
Machado,
you know,
I mean,
he submitted a lot of fucking really
good dudes.
Sarah was a killer and just straight
Jujitsu back when he was only competing
in Jiu Jitsu before he.
When you get into mixed martial arts,
of course you have to.
You have to dedicate so much time to
striking so much of your time to
conditioning so much of your time to do
all these different things that you
know,
your Jujitsu game doesn't get to express
itself the ways,
you know.
He's getting involved in a lot of stand
up fights and you know,
sometimes dudes like they,
one guy will take it down and hold onto
you.
It's you don't get to see it as if like
it was a straight Jujitsu match where
one guy only trying to submit you and
you're trying to submit him.
Then you get to really see a guy's
Jujitsu and Matt Serra has some fucking
top line Jujitsu.
His Jujitsu is really tight man and you
know,
to have a guy like him teaching a guy
like Weidman,
you know,
a guy was already fought mma many,
many times.
One the title,
you know what I mean?
Fought some of the best guys to have him
teaching Weidman.
You get a stud wrestler,
a guy who has beaten,
I believe he fought Phil Davis and
rather wrestled filled Davidson,
beat him in a straight wrestling
competition,
which is fucking crazy.
Davis is an amazing wrestler.
So weidman a killer wrestler and then on
top of that he's learned submissions and
on top of that he's just tough as fuck
off his phone and he's all crazy with
Jesus.
He's another one of those dudes that's
always crazy.
Loves Jesus and he's like super
religious and it's got that Jujitsu walk
hand in hand.
Yeah.
Will they get that mad belief in
themselves?
There's something to be said for that.
They used to scare the shit out of me
when I used to fight like religious
guys.
I obviously think that religious guy,
they always made me nervous like they
had like a kind of confidence that
fucking spooked and you can't beat them
up because you feel like they got the
fucking burn for an extra fucking week.
I wish you could come to Brazil.
Joey.
They start burning.
They get a passport and started fucking.
You've got to get a passport.
Shit like that.
Fucking people had the old country
confused to Christianity.
And how's that working for the Denver?
Are they still in it?
They ran into punches.
Pilot.
Who's punches pilot?
The motherfucker from England.
Tom Brady dumped his bitch when she was
six months pregnant.
Who's that?
And not just dumped a bunch of fucking
hot bitch and then jumped on the thing
where he put the phones on.
Tim Teebo his fucking head last week and
this week ray Lewis went up there
thinking he was going to the superbowl,
stabbed somebody else,
but you had a fucking stop up there too.
They didn't cover the spread,
but the under came
picker.
You see that kicker lesson and the
Patriot game?
Is that what it was?
The giant games.
This clobbered.
This kicker wasn't,
didn't know you were supposed to go up
or something.
I don't know what the full story is.
So at the last second he had to like run
and kick the ball,
you know,
he was like on the sidelines they
couldn't find them or anything and he
missed it and I think that was like the
kick that made them lose the superbowl
or something like that.
Oh my God.
You got one job to do in the kitchen.
And I was at that time he looked like
suicidal and like fans were like,
we didn't say anything bad to him
because he looked like he was suicidal.
It's like what some
of the quotes were saying fucking Bro.
Izzy last week.
Yeah,
he's a white John Jones.
Really?
Six,
five.
I didn't know that.
I was looking at him last week and his
gift is his hearing.
He lets them come around them and swat
at them and all of a sudden this fucking
dangerous because you don't even see it.
Like if I was in my going down and maybe
because I just am a punch.
Motherfuckers do Brady Hammer Punch
right from me.
A bag.
You want to take me down because I had
dated.
I dated a girl for my fucking thing.
I will hit you with a hammer part that
will crush your skull.
Joe.
They're putting their hands out.
He so Paul,
he stands in the pocket.
You don't run.
They don't move and he just watches and
all of a sudden when that dude's phone
that's then comes out man.
And that motherfucker.
I mean he made me a believer a couple of
years ago,
but I was sitting on this six foot five
bro.
He ain't no fucking joke that do.
When you see the guys around him,
he's fucking tall.
He's a big motherfucking strong.
I was watching him.
That's.
He's got some kind of place eating that
Brazilian chip that's to give you
something.
Does that help?
What's that?
Eating a Brazilian check made them a
little crazy because she's fucking
gotta.
Be Crazy.
If I was just out bumble,
say whatever her name is.
I did that taxi movie with her.
She was on the side.
I looked at that bitches ass.
That bitch was attend.
There was no cellulite and a future.
You understand me like her thighs have
no silly Leeton her future.
She's never gonna have that big Brazil.
Nothing she has meant meant.
Meant meant her malcontents.
I rubbed her when she was in the pussy.
They rubbed up with fucking cocoa butter
or whatever the fuck bitches banging.
I get taxi with that bitch.
She was in a plane with us and when the
plane landed,
they.
They rushed her off into a security card
and took her away.
Fuck.
You got a God that pussy pushing a box
year round.
They got to have a lock and a key and
flashlights.
I'll concur.
Concur.
Open it.
You have to let the air out of the
Monkey.
That crossfit,
that pussy is the real deal dog.
What's next for you joe?
What's going on?
What do you got going on?
You want to promote weeks?
I got the fuck we're doing.
Oh,
to Vegas.
February third house of Blues have sold
out already.
Getting on it.
Hiv Dot com.
You uh,
you can find it.
Just go see like a motherfucker.
It's either you or the priest.
$5 on payloads.
Fucking killing them.
And how do we find that?
How do people find the payloads?
Dotcom.
Payloads,
payloads with a z Dot d,
z.
that's it.
Payloads.
Diaper loads.
What are you going to do with all the
lowes.com?
And I'll tell you what,
it was one of the,
you know,
when I've never fucking been good at
taping anything.
Right?
And I've come to terms with that.
So what I did was I just bought one of
those things and took me to a month of
gigs.
Yeah.
Didn't say nothing.
Just plugged them into the boards
really.
And I got a set that was so fucking good
and I got full in the middle of one of
my assets because I was telling a true
story.
I go,
either you or the priest
and Felicia,
Felicia.
We went to a church while they were
doing the church service on Sunday.
I lankershim and we went up to the
[inaudible] priest thing and look at the
album cover.
It says priest up confessional.
And she took a picture while they were,
you get given a priest is up there,
you know,
give everybody thanks and praise.
It was a Catholic fucking pr.
So I said,
you know what man?
People always asked me for Shit,
I'll sell it for $5 downloads,
you know?
And that's it.
I don't have to get it on itunes.
I didn't put it on itunes yet.
I'm trying to get all night to get it
yet.
How do we get it on?
I can teach you that.
He doesn't get it.
Yeah,
we've got to get that on itunes.
We gotta make it easy to have one on
itunes now,
but one live from the three of clubs at
some men's,
a man's.
It's good,
but this one's really fun.
I mean,
listen,
I don't like watching myself watching
myself in the beginning of general
hospital and they focused on my bald
spot.
I fucking turned it off.
That's all I see is on Hulu Dot com.
You can you see me walk in.
I can't wait.
You're gonna die.
You're gonna die even died.
I was like,
oh,
except for the ball spot.
Jody is a bad motherfucker.
You know what I'm saying?
The boss Bot was killing a brother.
Are you going to do more?
How many guns did wind up doing?
I hope that they write me back in once
this guy sonny leaves,
because I really had a good time.
I got to tell I had a grilling.
It's me.
It's easy.
There's no drama and you know where you
stand.
There's no like pas telling you five
minutes come up,
get changed.
No,
there's nothing.
I'm always amazed that someone that
hasn't figured out to put you in a
sitcom.
I just don't drive me crazy.
So cartoony.
Then you should be a voice of a cartoon
adventure time.
Once they get the word's getting out
that we're doing great things.
I'm going to do great things this year.
You know,
it's amazing.
Make us a cartoon.
We're going to go,
uh,
we're going to do a desk squad tour to.
We're working on that right now for the
spring we're working on.
It'll be everybody that's on the
podcast,
you know,
one of those things.
It'll be like we're trying to do one
with already Duncan Joe and meet with a
bunch of us Kreischer.
Get as many of us together as we can and
hit some theaters.
Just hit somebody.
Awesome.
One of those long ones.
Fucking emails this week.
And I want you to use your head people.
Everybody keeps saying to you guys and
Joe going to hang out after the show.
Yeah,
but there's only one problem.
It's going to be four degrees.
So unless you had joined is fucking made
out of an Igloo or something or fucking
a non freezed papers.
We'll meet you outside.
There's going to be three degrees.
Nowhere to go,
so I hope that we do post an after party
somewhere.
So we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Have a party.
We're going to see these people.
I want to do that thing with Pete.
The cop,
the cop offered us some club and I'll
announce it at the uh,
at the actual shoe.
Yeah.
That's the best move for me to do
nothing.
And that's part of the fingers.
These meet a lot of people though inside
when we sell the posters to find.
So it'll be cool,
man.
I'm going to feel for it.
Before you leave,
did you see that fucking cruise ship
ship that sunk?
Do you know those people?
A bunch of people are dead.
At least 20 people were dead.
A bunch of people are missing or 12
people are dead.
You are dead.
They just found two or three more bodies
last night.
They're exploding a holes in it to
today.
You can get to more places
to find them.
And I think there's 15.
Well,
the cruise ship company started calling
up the passengers saying that they would
offer them 30 percent off their next
vacation with them.
That's nice.
That's a great discount code.
That's I imagine people that have jumped
into the ocean to save their lives with
their children.
They should get free cruise for life.
How would you imagine fucking cruise
ship ever again?
Fucking paid me.
I went on one time to the cruise to
nowhere in New York.
Twenty four hours.
I knew that shit wasn't trap.
I don't like it at all.
Oh,
they got great food.
They got nothing.
They got fucking all you can eat and you
gotta you gotta go out to the gallery.
The smoke dope.
No,
no,
no.
Just leading me on dry fucking land.
Anthony to Mia likes going on cruises
doesn't mean.
I don't know.
I think he likes just going and getting
hammered and going on cruises.
I hate you.
I don't.
I can't get it.
But the captain,
the captain is totally to blame.
Apparently.
Just drove it into the rocks.
This crazy.
Yeah.
So.
And he jumped off for four hours before
the last passenger got off.
This asshole was off.
Took her.
He just took off.
He crashed the fucking boat.
Could you imagine you,
you,
you know,
you spend billions of dollars and your
cruise line keeping everything
maintained perfect and some asshole
drives your big and supposedly bus into
a rock
and supposedly it was like something
that same path that he did every day for
years,
but he got bored and said there was one
part where you just wanted to do
something different because you know,
and so you went to a different way that
you really.
Yeah,
because you can track it.
You can track the crews on this website
to see where boats go every single day.
Imagine the audacity of
company to call you just a few days
after,
you know people lost loved ones.
People.
There's people missing still too,
for a company to have the audacity to
call you up and say,
hey,
we're going to offer you 30 percent off
your next cruise just because we want
you to.
You know what the price of that cruise
that you just almost died in.
We're going to fuck it.
Throw that out the window.
How about that?
We're going to race that.
We're going to get like,
they're so delusional.
They think they're so detached,
they think those people are ever going
to get on a fucking cruise again.
That fuck that man,
that's you,
you,
you got a little piece of metal that's
floating over an alien world and at any
point in time something can happen and a
whole could get punctured to that thing
and then it sinks to the bottom of that
era alien world where you can't live and
then what are you in?
Then you're in a little floatable raft
bobbing around in shark soup and all
this time
this has happened when Brendan Walsh and
Doug Benson had been on this cruise ship
with weed and like all these bands and
stuff.
This happened at the same time while
they're online and you could know Doug's
probably don't as an elegant way to,
uh,
Doug Benson and Brendan Walsh,
or on a cruise ship.
Yeah.
With weezer and Wean and a bunch of
people.
It's like a,
it's a weezer careers where they're just
all in this huge boat.
Yeah.
That actually sounds kind of see that,
that,
that made a crew sound.
All right.
If you can get a bunch of cool bands,
but you know,
imagine Doug's just being on that boat
with Doug [inaudible],
you know,
you're probably smoking shit loads of
weed and you hear about that happening.
You're probably like,
oh my God,
we're on a boat when it.
Where are they?
Where are they traveling?
I don't know if you Google weezer cruise
back yet.
I think they came back yesterday.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's bring this shit back around the
harbor,
so to speak.
Poor choice of words.
No Pun intended.
Quite honestly.
Just slipped up.
Powerful.
Joe.
I love you.
We'll see you in Chicago.
It's going to be fucking off the chain.
I'm training all week.
I'm ready.
Oh,
pleasure.
Hang with you.
My brother has always fucking grave when
we eat some Italian sausage sandwiches.
You want to go to dinner with us
tonight?
Come on Hollywood tonight.
You have set side.
There were fucking savage already.
Dirty freaks.
Like I said,
Chicago almost sold out.
There's a link on my twitter page.
You can find it somewhere on Joe
Rogan.net
as well.
Um,
ticket master site.
It's almost done.
There's just the nosebleeds left.
We're going to have a good fucking time
though.
Duncan trussell.
Joe Diaz as me,
we're so excited to be there.
I can't fucking wait and then the next
night is the UFC on Fox.
I'm fucking fired up for this and we'll
be with you motherfuckers.
You know what I'm saying?
Thank you to the flashlight for
sponsoring our podcast.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
entering the code name Brogan.
You will get 15 percent off.
Number one,
sex toy from me and thank you also to
onnit.com,
o n n I t.com,
the makers of Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
true tech,
immune and new mood.
All of them are nootropics.
All of them are essentially vitamins for
your mind,
please Google nootropics,
please,
please educate yourself on the subject
before you go and buy anything.
If you think about buying it,
but it's too expensive,
I urge you to go by the recipe in bulk
and put it together yourself.
Steal our own ingredients.
I welcome it.
I want you people to feel happy much
more than I want to make money,
so if you buy any of this stuff and you
don't like it,
you get 100 percent of your money back.
It's,
it's clean as I can make it.
There's no other way to be more honest
about it.
That's all we have for you folks.
So go to [inaudible] dot com.
Enter in the code name Rogan.
Get yourself 10 percent off pitches this
Wednesday.
We'll be joined by the one and only the
lovely Mr Duncan trussell and that will
will kick off the desk.
Can I give a shot real quick?
Fuck yeah.
Cc your choices.
The vine wellness for the best edibles
and fucking north Hollywood and tainted
vision art dot Com.
I love you.
Muddle.
Next week after,
after Chicago.
What do you say about you and and
Felicia know you and Felicia coming to
the podcast?
Come into Pasadena and we'll do it in
the passenger before Vegas.
Yes.
Before,
before Vegas,
which will be a third.
Tickets are on sale now at House of
Blues and Vegas.
Unfortunately there's going to be
standing room.
There's going to be people that have to
stand in the back of it.
That's all we could get.
I hate standing shows.
I avoid them like the plague,
but it was standing show or no show.
We had to go with the static shows.
The other place,
the Mandalay Bay theater that we always
perform at is being renovated.
They're doing some crazy.
Michael Jackson show there,
so we really want to talk about Carlos
conduit yet.
We'll do that next week.
That's next week to fucking blow up.
That's going to be spectacular.
That I love you.
We might have to do one with you and
joey for that one.
Oh,
you and Eddie rather you would have
died.
That's what we'll do next week.
Next week.
You dirty freaks subscribed to the desk
squad on itunes.
It's number six right now and that is on
the power of the Brian callen show,
which is the most recent podcast added
to the desk squad label and of course
ice house chronicles,
which is the second most recent and my
favorite podcast of the week.
We do that one at the ice house.
We have all the comics come in and sit
down.
This past week we had a Bert Kreischer,
Dane Cook.
A Ra should fear was on.
It's a fucking.
It's a hang.
It's a real look into the green room,
completely uncensored.
It's the real deal.
It's really comics hanging out before
the show and then we jump up at the ice
house,
which is one of the oldest and most
respected clubs in the country.
Happens to be in Pasadena,
California.
That's where we do our thing.
That's quite.tv,
[inaudible] dot TV.
We'll see you guys on Wednesday.
Thanks for tuning in.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for all the positive tweets and
all the love and all the energy.
We love you from the bottom of my heart.
This is a movement.
We're all part of this shit together.
This is the reason why this works is
because of you guys.
It's all together.
We respect you.
We appreciate it.
We tweet and everything that we find.
It's cool.
We're all connected together in this
motherfucker.
Let's keep it together.
Bitches.
They black.